Who Du du Du Du,
Du Du,
alice
and Roseanne.
Joe Rogan.
We made it happen finally years,
years in the making.
Here I am.
I know.
It's one of those things that we talked
about it like 30 times.
I know.
Well thank you so much for having me.
It's my birthday.
No less.
Oh Shit.
Happy Birthday.
Thank you know.
Right?
That's right.
Finally,
I have my first drink so much to write
what I've been drinking for years
illegally.
Come on.
We shouldn't admit that.
All of you.
For Real,
you'll have to tell you.
Are you one of those people?
No,
I,
I.
It's obscene.
It's obscene how old I've become.
How old are you?
Forty one.
Oh,
that's how I'm seen.
I'm 40 years.
Really?
Yes.
That's obscene.
I'm almost 40 minutes.
I'm almost 50 happy.
Almost birthday.
I'll be 50 in a couple months.
In a year.
Wow.
How do you feel about that?
Sexy as fuck for great.
Feel like you're making almost 50 look
good.
I also feel like there's a hair stuck to
my lip,
so for anyone watching and if there's
like a fuzzball on my face,
I'm sorry.
It's just a 41 year old thing.
I don't think we have a r a.
h,
d is not that strong.
I really should've just left it there.
Then whatever it is that the length that
I've collected since arriving deep in
the valley.
One thing I do realize though as I get
older is like maintaining health is like
an effort.
You have to be a lot more aware of
making sure you eat the right stuff.
Making sure you,
you know,
make sure you exercise on a regular
basis.
Don't get attache because you'd get out
of shape.
It's again,
it's way harder to get back in right
now.
Did you are such a healthy guy.
Did you ever go through a phase when you
were younger of being unhealthy?
Not really,
no.
I never went through like a binge
drinking or fat phase.
I mean,
I've gotten overweight slightly before,
but even then I'd look at myself,
I'm like,
you're fucking disgusting.
Slob like,
get it together.
I just,
um,
it's,
you know,
there's,
there's two schools of thought on it and
one school of thought is that if you
spend too much time on your body that
you're vain and this is a frivolous
pursuit because you're going to die
anyway and it's all pointless,
but I feel like that's kind of a cop out
because I think that the only have this
one meet vehicle to get you through this
life and if it was a car,
you'd maintain it.
If you have a nice car,
what do you do?
You take care of the oil,
you know,
you,
you get it serviced,
you deal with all the stuff that makes
it run nice and I think that you've got
to do that with your body.
At least for me,
I have to do that with my body.
If I don't,
I don't feel.
And I feel like I'm slacking off in a
way that's lazy and irresponsible and
stupid.
I just died.
I just see too many people with health
consequences because they don't take
care of their bodies.
I think it depends.
I think if you're saying it's self
absorbed and it's a vein and it's
shallow to care about your body and if
you're saying that as an excuse to
allow yourself to not get into shape,
then I think that you're not really
facing what's going on.
And like that thing where you're like,
oh,
it's just shallow.
That's just,
that's not,
you're not really addressing what the
actual resistance is.
I don't know.
I think for me,
um,
I got into a phase where I was going to
a personal trainer and I got really into
it and for the first time all this stuff
that I'd heard my whole life about how
sport,
because I'm not a sports person.
So about how sports can affect the rest
of your life.
I never understood that.
I never understood the mental part of
it.
But,
but for that time,
and I'm not really in that place
anymore,
but for the time that I was super into
it,
I felt better.
I definitely did.
And I felt like I can put in effort in
the gym and it's the effects.
Not In terms of what you see on my body.
But how I feel are immediate and uh,
and also that thing of like,
this is a challenge for me,
but I'm going to dig deep and I'm going
to do it and I like set these little
goals for myself every day,
almost every day that I could overcome.
And that was kind of insane that
feeling,
how good I felt when I did something
that I didn't think I could do.
And it was happening,
you know,
multiple times a week.
I just think it's,
it's almost,
I mean it's not overlooked with a lot of
people,
but with some people that is overlooked.
And I think it's unfortunate because
it's thought of as like a vain pursuit
or pursuit of vanity.
And it's,
it,
it really restructures the way your
brain functions when you,
when you regularly exercise and your
body pumps out all those endorphins and
you release all that stress and your
body sweats.
And it just,
it just feels like it's flowing better.
Like everything's go like your,
your decisions are better.
The way you feel about things is better.
You leave the gym,
you have a smile on your face.
He like driving your car,
the sun feels better,
right?
Well,
and that thing where it's like,
I did something healthy for me today.
Can I ask a question about something
that you said earlier that actually kind
of ties into all of this?
You said that when the times of your
life where you would get a tiny bit
overweight,
you'd look in the mirror and you think
like,
Oh,
you forget exactly what you said,
but like,
oh,
ew,
disgusting fat Slob or something.
I've been thinking a lot lately about
the ways that we talk to ourselves
because I can be so,
so brutal on myself.
And I've really,
as I've gotten older and I think we've
made it clear,
I'm very old.
Um,
I've,
I've tried to go more gentle on myself
because it's like I don't speak to
anyone the way I speak to myself,
but I do.
Well,
here's the question.
Do you think there's good that comes out
of being really shitty to yourself?
The good is the reaction to that.
What you don't like that feeling and
then you do something different.
Because I think if you just look at
yourself and look in the mirror,
go also
you
tuck your gut into your shirt and Tuck
your shirt into your pants and you just
go about your day and then have a heart
attack.
Didn't.
I don't think you're going to get the
results that you really want.
I think if you.
If you want your body to work well,
you have to be honest and if you have
slacked off and you have gained weight
or you have eaten a bunch of shitty food
and you feel like really just slow and
sludgy and you know that feeling that
you get if you just indulge too much or
drink too much that oh that just that
the drinking too much of a bad one.
Like last time we did that podcast here
with Stan hope I fucking tried to brush
my teeth with deodorant,
deodorant out,
and I had my toothbrush.
I'm like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Like my brain was so scrambled from just
getting hammered.
Like that's just a bad feeling.
It's fun while you're doing it.
I believe there's an expression,
I forgot.
Who Was it?
Oscar Wilde,
uh,
all things in moderation.
Including moderation.
Yes.
I think it's a great expression.
I think you got to enjoy your life,
but man,
that feeling after indulging is where
your body is just wrecked.
It's a terrible feeling.
And I think the only way to for me at
least to move past that as we go.
All right,
fuck face no more of that stupid shit.
And then get on
the right track.
I would find back when I used to indulge
in everything more the feeling of
indulging in the feeling of I'm doing
something that I don't think I'm really
okay with the fact that I'm doing it
made me feel a strange from myself.
And then it's like I want to keep the
party going.
There were so many nights because I
don't,
I'm,
I don't,
I don't indulge in much anymore because
I ate,
was kind of getting out of hand.
And this is many years ago that I'm
talking about because I've been on the
planet a lot of years.
Um,
I'll,
I'll stop with that.
I'll fucking call yourself.
That's a true podcast and like some
people,
my father said no,
I'm not sure when I'll start with it,
but I think I'll stop with it.
Um,
but you know,
I would be out and it would be 1:30 2:30
the time when most people would just go
home and I didn't,
I didn't want to go home because I
didn't want to be with myself.
I just wanted to go home with whatever
guy I was talking to in the moment.
MMM.
Okay.
So you just wanted to escape.
Yes,
yes.
I wanted to escape and then I wanted to
escape myself.
Wow,
that's interesting.
That's a very honest way of looking at
it and I think a lot of people feel like
that,
like the,
a lot of what the partying is
distraction from their own problems or
their own.
The goals that they haven't tried to go
after,
those sort of nagging problems in their
life they're not working on totally does
destroy it.
The mind works in such a weird way where
you chase after distractions sometimes
with all this vigor,
but you don't do the same with the
actual real issues in your life.
You don't chase after them because it
doesn't.
There's no immediate gratification in
doing so.
Yeah,
but there's not.
I mean even the immediate gratification
and chasing after distractions,
it's so obvious
what you're doing,
why you're doing it may not always to
yourself though.
No,
I guess not.
It is.
If you're paying attention,
but most times you not.
It's weird how many different sorts of
mechanisms the brain has in place to
protect you from all the blind spots,
from discomfort and all the things that
are wrong with your approach.
Yeah.
I mean I sort of feel like when that
tells me is this an a self absorbed way
to go through the world.
I kind of feel like the point of being
on this earth,
one of the points is self awareness and
to figure out what you're doing and why
you're doing it and to kind of become
self actualized.
It certainly helps you be more efficient
in what you're doing and also realize
what it is you actually enjoy.
Yeah.
I think at the end of the day it's an
experience and it's an experience that
restarts every day.
You know,
you go to bed,
it shuts off.
You wake up and you go,
here we go again,
and you assume that this is the same
life and you assume that you're not just
waking up in some sort of computer
program that pretends that you have 41
years of memories.
You go about your day and if you want to
make the most out of it,
you have to be aware of these mistakes
that you keep repeating and sort of just
try to not do that anymore and try to
get better.
And you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to fucking start eating Vegan.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna Start taking yoga.
You know what I'm going to do?
I want to start at end.
You look at these things as like a
positive sort of directions that you
could get on that maybe will change and
then you like fall off the Vegan wagon
or you follow the yoga wagon,
you start drinking again and it's like
this constant cycle with a lot of people
have like,
you know,
going on diets and then fucking up and
eating cake,
starting an exercise program and then
getting fat again.
And it's,
I think being self aware helps you to
have moments of reflection and I think
meditation is really important too.
That's a big one that a lot of people
don't like to do.
Spend time alone by yourself doing
nothing.
Do Twenty minutes a day to sit down and
breathe,
sit down and think and they will help
you tremendously it because we're on
momentum all the time.
Yes.
I actually,
yesterday I began to feel overwhelmed,
um,
just from this a bunch of stuff going on
and in the moment I was just like,
I felt kind of shaky and I'm happy to
say I did not go to the kitchen and try
to find something to eat,
you know,
like sort of my old things that I
would've done.
I just,
I made myself take some deep breaths and
tried to calm down.
I don't know how well it worked,
but at least I felt like that was a
healthy way to deal with it in a moment.
I think it definitely worked.
Right,
because you're talking about it.
So that's true.
Well,
I'm here today so you made it,
but
you know what I mean,
like you,
you,
you're aware that you wanted to reset
your thinking.
So he spent some time and he took some
deep breaths and you reset your
thinking.
I think that's real important for people
because how many times do you just in
a momentous react?
I state this girl,
she's so crazy.
Road rage.
It was hilarious because she wasn't like
a big girl or a dangerous girl or
anything like that.
When someone cut her off,
she's like,
you motherfucker.
And she would,
she would like gun the gas and get
beside them and swerve in front of them.
She was so crazy.
She's from Chicago,
Chicago people.
I'm just kidding.
But she was just like really aggressive
that way and I,
you know,
I had to tell her,
I go,
you can't do that with me in the car go
because we could die like,
this is fucking stupid,
like your,
your butt.
And she was just like so caught up in
the momentum of her emotions and this
motherfucker thinks he can cut me off
bitch.
Or maybe it was like this thing that she
had done like all the time and she'd
never thought about it and addressing it
and calming down breathing.
She was like,
yeah,
I guess I should probably stop doing
that.
But it's this momentum of this pattern
of behavior that's cut so deep.
It's such a groove that you always
comfortably fall into like your
coffee
proof coffee in my throat.
Um,
it's like,
it's like written into your operating
software,
there are certain people that are
programmed to see the world in a way
where it's like people are trying to
screw me over and I'm not going to let
that happen.
And so they'll see it everywhere.
Even where it isn't skews the coffee in
my throat.
I to stop drinking this stuff.
We should come up with a better way
maybe that emulsified mct oil.
Maybe that's the move without the
butter.
Give it a shot.
Let's next move.
Sorry.
No,
that's it.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
I think everybody does that.
I think it's,
it's,
it's normal and especially if it's,
if you have been fucked over before,
then you start thinking,
oh,
it's everywhere,
goddammit.
These fucking people.
Yeah.
I'm not going to be blindsided again.
It's when you actually do actually get
fucked over,
like in a business deal or with someone
who's trying to fuck you over,
like financially or something like that.
It's like,
it's very disturbing.
oh,
this is a real criminal.
I'm involved with the criminal.
Someone's trying to rob me.
Has that happened to you?
Yeah,
definitely and when it does happen it's
you just realize like,
Whoa,
okay,
all right,
well some people this is what they do
and you have to now throw that into the
mix.
Like this is a possibility.
Some people would just kind of try to
steal money from you.
For me,
I would need to go back.
It's still,
it still affected my throat.
Excuse me.
I would need to,
I would,
I would become,
I would begin to think about everything
and I'd be like when was the point at
which this started and I'd have to kind
of reconsider everything and that is my
own obsession with certified.
We were talking before,
the way that I can prevent this
happening in the future is to really
understand how this happened now,
but I think I get a little too.
I mean I can really like I can,
I can ruminate on something too much.
Yeah,
I think we all can,
you know,
I think also if something's important to
you and you,
you know,
you really,
you want something to work out well,
whether it's a podcast you're doing or
comedy show or something like that,
you're getting,
you can kind of obsess on things too
much.
You can get so involved in the details
that you kind of,
you know,
the old expression,
you can't see the forest for the trees.
But like what we were saying earlier
about the or I was saying about trying
to talk to myself differently.
This um,
this might map barf because it's so,
it's so hippy dippy,
new age like stuart smalley almost.
But
lately I've been thinking like is that a
loving behavior towards myself that I'm
engaging in?
So if I'm ruminating about something,
are obsessing about something or
thinking about something that's
upsetting me.
Like is that am I being loving towards
myself?
And then in thinking that way after I
finished vomiting,
I think it like,
it allow,
it allows me to actually kind of move
on.
I like put those thoughts down,
which is a pretty new thing for me
because I have been at the mercy of my
thoughts always.
Well for me,
I think I try to avoid a lot of negative
behavior and negative thinking because
if I allow it,
um,
and I,
I always think of myself as like,
okay,
if I was giving myself advice,
how would I,
how would I treat it?
What would I,
I'd probably be pretty brutally honest.
So negative thinking and negative
behavior.
I try to avoid it almost for the
consequences of me,
the chastising myself.
Like I don't want to chastise myself.
I like,
I want to like me,
so if I'm fucking up,
like I don't want to hear me going,
come on Pussy,
get it together.
So there's,
there's that part of me like it's almost
like a drill instructor is like looking
over my shoulder,
making sure that I don't fuck
[inaudible] like bitch,
I'm right here.
Like,
I know what you're doing is stupid,
you know,
don't,
don't do,
don't get dumb.
And I've been dumb and I think we have
all been dumb and I just think all that
self love and self help is great,
but not if it allows you to continue the
same patterns over and over again and
still love yourself.
That's yes.
That's where you have to really be
honest and make sure that your rig
rigorously honest with yourself,
you can still love yourself and tell
yourself you're a fat fuck.
Sometimes that's the most loving thing.
Gently,
lovingly.
Tell myself I'm a fat.
Fuck you say it was a giant,
sweet smile.
That's the loving part.
Yeah,
well it's,
it's,
you know,
it's not bad to be honest.
You know,
and you still love yourself.
Even if you've been eating cake all day,
like,
look,
I love you,
but you're gonna fucking die of an
insulin crash here.
See,
that's where.
That's where it's like,
is it loving it,
man,
I'm really married to this barfy idea.
Is it loving to eat cake all day?
No,
that's not.
You're not treating yourself right.
If you're doing that,
you know the real
problem is that mouth pleasure is not
even that good.
Like the mouth pleasure that you get
from eating cake is the first thinking
about that.
This is like the first bite or the
second bite maybe,
but then when you get deep into it,
it's kind of sickening that yes,
you just keep going.
Like my kid had a birthday party the
other day and we eat her cake and I was
like,
Oh fucking Christ.
This stuff is so disgusting.
I have a tiny little bit because I'm
like,
you get into it and especially if you
don't need a lot of cake,
like after like the third or fourth
bite,
like,
oh,
like this fucking pasty frosting and
sugar and
are you one of those people who pushes
all the frosting to the side and was
like,
oh,
it's too sweet.
I can't.
I'll just have a bite of the wheat germ.
No,
I go for the frost at first.
Everybody does.
That's where the love is.
Although that's true.
I gave up carbs for about a year.
All carbs,
all carbs.
Like,
I was very strict about it,
I was looking at even,
I was trying not to Overdo,
I was kind of kind of trying to do like
strict,
strict Atkins.
So eventually I allowed more vegetables
in.
But at the beginning I was trying not to
go overboard with that.
And um,
what was your,
what was your response to that?
Your body's response at the beginning?
So my story is,
um,
I was pretty overweight.
I'm growing up and into my twenties and
then,
I mean I kinda gone up and down and then
I finally lost the bulk of it and I've
kept it off for years,
but about a year ago it started creeping
back on a little bit because I'm doing
ivf,
I'm trying to get pregnant and I'm
shooting myself with hormones all the
time.
Um,
and all the things in the past,
all the ways in the past that I'd kept
the weight off because it had been about
10 years of really being careful with my
calories and exercising and all that.
Like it just wasn't working anymore and
it was freaking me the fuck out.
So that's when I started going to a
personal trainer and that's when I,
um,
and it was not his advice.
I don't know what made me decide to do
it.
I was like,
maybe if I just cut out all carbs,
that'll help.
So at the beginning I did lose weight,
um,
but then it no longer helped in terms of
the,
like,
not then at a certain point I realized,
Oh,
the weight comes on at a certain point
in the ivf cycle and then comes back off
in between cycles and goes back and I
realized that I had been freaking out.
But it's just,
it's just cycling on its own for people
that are freaking out right now in vitro
fertilization,
in vitro fertilization is where,
uh,
they fertilize your eggs outside of your
body.
It acts in vitro is in glass,
is what it means,
and it's a way that people who can't get
pregnant naturally can get pregnant.
I'm so in,
it involves injecting a lot of hormones
and it's a whole,
it's a whole thing.
Uh,
so anyway,
it was affecting my weight.
I believe that now that is what was
affected my weight,
but I was freaking out at the time.
So initially there was some weight loss
and then that stopped,
but I found for a while I enjoyed living
within very strict guidelines.
It was just easier when we go to a
restaurant because I used to joke that I
would like to be buried in a bread
basket with a fuck ton of butter.
Bread and butter is my thing.
Um,
and when we go to a restaurant and they
bring the bread,
like I just,
I don't even touch it.
It's not mine.
I just,
it was so,
it was nice to not even have to think
about all these things.
Um,
but then,
I don't know,
a few months ago I just thought,
I don't feel like this is really doing
anything for me anymore.
And I miss my lean cuisine dinners,
which is what I used to eat.
Cuisine.
They're not,
I of all the things you can miss.
Well,
healthy choice dinners as well with the,
with that process.
Bullshit.
I know I had stopped eating the process,
which I missed.
I missed the bullshit I missed.
I missed the wood pulp.
Wood wood is wood pulp.
It's probably some kind of filler in
there.
I'm just saying like wood pulp in your
food.
In parmesan cheese.
I think that come out recently.
What?
Right.
Jamie knows Jamie.
What are you talking about?
What?
What kind of Parmesan cheese and just
the,
you know the bottle of kraft.
Parmesan cheese.
It came out that a certain percentage of
it is like wood shavings or something.
Jesus Christ.
Why are they putting in your cheese so
that there's a bigger plants though,
right?
Cheese.
You sprinkle what?
Cellulose.
Okay.
Hotly contested,
but perhaps not for reasons.
My think FDA investigation found that a
Pennsylvania company,
castle cheese incorporated had doctored.
It's so called Parmesan with a mix of
cheap cheddar cheese and cellulose.
Also known as wood pulp.
Oh,
well you say cellulose.
That doesn't sound like cellulose.
Just sounds like like fiber from plants.
Plant material.
Well,
there shouldn't be plant material and
fucking cheese.
You
asshole should go to jail for that.
Putting fucking wouldn't cheese.
You can't just do that and you can't mix
cheddar cheese with wood and call it
Parmesan so it should have its own new
variety,
name wood,
pulp,
cheesy thing.
Just call it that.
People would buy it.
My mouth is watering.
Well,
you're eating lean cuisine insane.
I don't know what it is in the processed
frozen dinners that I like,
but that's what I like.
Sort of like when I smoked I was like,
yeah,
I think it's the fiberglass in the
cigarettes that I like.
When my wife was pregnant,
she liked Tony knows pizza rolls,
you know those little fucking disgusting
things.
I've not had them,
but I've seen them in the freezer
section.
I was buying them for him.
I can't believe you're actually wanting
to eat this shit.
She ate healthy most of the time,
but like she would just one of like vege
out and sit there holding onto her beach
ball stomach.
Tony knows pizza rolls now.
How
are you toward your wife and your kids
in terms of beat them up?
Do whatever the fuck I want to know how
my diet.
Yeah,
and in terms of being rigorously honest
or letting them kind of come to their
own conclusions,
I
don't need to do that with my wife.
She's on the ball,
know she,
she's pretty healthy too,
but she also likes to indulge but she's
not,
she's pretty,
pretty balanced in terms of like how she
approaches diet and exercise and healthy
eating and then occasionally indulging.
She's balanced.
Luckily that's not an issue and for my
kids,
you know,
with kids the big struggle is trying to
keep them from eating too much sugar.
Like I don't want to be that guy that
says you can't have sugar.
Like she has some kids in her class.
One of my daughters does,
um,
this is one kid in particular that's on
this insane diet.
Like he doesn't eat any sugar,
there's nothing processed and the kid's
freaking out all the time because all
around them kids are eating cake and
having all these things and I feel like
that can set you up psychologically so
in,
in a bad way where you develop this,
where you want to bench later or.
Um,
yeah,
I think uh,
when your parents tell you not to eat,
you want to eat,
you know,
when you tell parents telling you not to
be a slut,
it's the first thing you want to do,
right?
It's what everybody does,
you know,
don't drink.
I can't wait to drink,
you know,
the,
the suppression is just not good for
human beings.
And so what I try to tell them is you
can have a little sugar but you have to
be aware that sugar is just not good for
your body.
It tastes good,
but it has consequences.
So like when we'd go halloween trick or
treating,
you know,
we'd let them have a couple of pieces of
candy,
you know,
like you can have a couple of weeks,
you just can't sit and eat that shit
until you go into a coma.
It's not good for you.
So sometimes they repeat it like I don't
like when I eat too much sugar and it
just makes me feel terrible.
But then sometimes like my youngest
fucking crazy,
my youngest is a little like a little
barbarian.
She'll eat sugar and then run around the
house.
Rory wrote like,
she just stormed the beaches,
she throws her arms back.
It shows you like run around the house,
like sugar it up.
I'm like,
this is insane.
We just gave her a rocket fuel or
something.
Because you think about like a little
tiny body,
right?
My youngest is five,
almost six and she's,
I don't know what she weighs.
Probably less than 50 pounds,
so if you give her a fucking candy bar,
like how much sugar's a God damn candy
bar and it's going in that tiny little
body and she just reacts to it.
She's like,
oh,
like she'll just chase me,
she'll kick me.
She fucking tries to tackle me.
She just goes nuts.
She's like really,
really physical.
When and when she's like sugared up,
it's like super obvious.
I'm like that.
I mean,
as long as she's burning it off,
I feel like let her just run around so
she gets crazy and burn it off,
but it's like her five hour energy with
worse doesn't really last five hours.
Last about 40 minutes.
And then there's a crash.
Like,
Daddy,
I don't feel tired.
I just want to lie.
It's hilarious because you know,
they don't,
they don't have any experience in life,
you know,
so when they taste the sugar it tastes
good.
They eat it,
they have this feeling like,
you know,
like,
oh,
I have a sugar rush coming on right now.
Nope.
They don't think like that.
They just go.
I knew,
but you know,
I'm not 100 percent strict but I do make
them eat vegetables.
That's the one thing I do.
I make them eat vegetables and I try to
keep them away from shitty food and I
try just try to explain why it's good.
Like this is why daddy likes to eat
this.
Like they always mock me that I don't
eat bread and you know,
they like to stick things in front of my
face that they eat and I don't eat.
But most of the time I don't suppress
them.
I try to just keep it like even when
they do something wrong,
one of the first things that I say is I
did way worse than you.
Like if,
if you,
if they did something wrong.
I said ice,
do that all the time.
When I was your age,
a matter of fact,
I think you're smarter than me,
like you're better at than me and I
always do that.
I always reinforce that.
Every mistake you've made,
I've made everything you've done.
I've done.
If you lied,
I've lied.
Like if I catch him lying about
something,
not telling the truth,
I just say,
look,
I just want to tell you when I was
little,
I lied all the time and I didn't want to
lie,
but I didn't want to get in trouble.
And so I would just lost that.
True.
Or is that a lie though?
Um,
I did some lion.
Yeah,
for sure.
definitely.
I think every kid has.
Um,
but I was just,
I just wanted to enforce in their head
like this.
You're not going to not love you.
I'm not gonna.
I just.
This is a part of life.
I think that's so great.
That's such a respectful way to raise
your kids.
I try to treat them like they're little
human beings that I know more than they
know.
I don't think of him as my kids in that.
Like I own them.
I think of them like they're my kids in
terms of I love them deeply but not like
a,
I don't own you like you're a little
human being.
And I also think that setting them up
like that gives them a certain amount of
autonomy and a certain amount of
independence that I think is really
critical to develop early on.
So that's not a giant shock when you
turn 18,
you know,
slowly build them into this idea.
You are a little autonomous human being
then I'm always going to be here.
Like if you need advice,
if you need a hug,
if you need,
you know,
you always got a place to sleep.
You don't have to worry like
everything's fine.
Like don't,
don't go through life with fear and
hunger,
you know that you don't have to worry
about that.
You have a family,
but you're your own thing.
Like what are you into you in the music,
what do you do?
You like space,
you know,
when you get into like reading books,
like what's your fucking thing?
Find your thing.
And I never had that chance as a kid,
you know,
and I think I'm looking at my life,
I'm like back at like the things that
happened to me that made me sort of like
rebel and made me sort of reinforced the
idea that I need to be independent.
I need to get the fuck away from all
these people need to have stopped all
this negative input coming from all
these different directions.
Like I sort of inhabit children,
get a chance to what I would have liked
about my own childhood.
Did you have an oppressive upbringing?
Wasn't oppressive?
It just was.
There wasn't a lot of attention is like
I just,
my parents really just weren't into it,
you know,
this,
I think that there was a lot of latchkey
kids in our generation.
And um,
I mean I used to.
I walk out the door when I was seven and
wander through the neighborhood.
I used to do it.
I did a fisherman's wharf magic show
when I was eight years old.
What the fuck?
Let's their eight year old.
Like my daughter just turned eight.
One of my daughters did.
And uh,
I couldn't imagine her just walking out
my house in San Francisco and wandering
down the street and being by herself
with no one,
I can't imagine that.
And so I,
I would think about like,
what my parents let me do and,
you know,
made me independent and a lot of ways,
but God put me in so much danger.
There's so many times.
Yeah.
I think if you're forced to be an adult
when you're a child,
you pay for it somehow later.
No,
I'm sure.
You sure.
I'm sure there's pros and cons,
you know,
if you can get through it all,
you have a more comprehensive view of
the world and the dangers are provided.
But I mean that was almost molested when
I was like eight by some fucking creep
at a library that I was hanging out at
the library and saved me.
I was,
I'm looking through.
I was in the monster movies when I was a
little kid.
I was really into like,
Dracula and Frankenstein and shit.
So I was looking through these books and
this guy came up to me and he was like,
really weird.
And um,
he said,
you know,
you like a monster books.
And I go,
yeah.
He goes,
ah,
I really,
I love monster books.
I've got some monster books in my car.
Do you want to see him on my hands?
Exactly.
Something like,
okay,
you know,
I didn't know any better.
And so I started walking with them in
the library and starts yelling at me
because she had seen me there before.
And you know,
she's real nice lady and she's like
yelling,
Joseph,
you get away from that man.
He just got out of prison and the Guy
Ran,
he ran and I just started crying.
I couldn't believe it.
You know,
I remember thinking at the time like,
who the fuck just lets a little kid just
wander around like,
like they do.
So time you thought that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I remember thinking that at the time.
Like,
why the fuck am I just wandering around
here?
Did you tell your parents?
Yeah.
What's fucked up is my mom didn't
remember it.
Like I talked to my mom about it
recently.
She didn't remember.
Mike,
how do you not remember?
This guy tried to molest me when I was
eight.
He got upset at her.
What was her reaction to see you're
getting upset?
It's just that was that latch key thing
like,
yeah,
you're fine.
Look,
you didn't.
Nothing happened.
You know,
it's like they have this attitude.
Well,
I think for the longest time that was
the attitude of like,
look,
I can't,
I kept you physically safe.
You're in clothing.
You went to school,
whatever it is,
you know,
so what's the problem?
And it's like,
well,
there's all the whole emotional side of
things.
Well,
I think when you look at our generation
versus our parent's generation and their
parents generation,
if you just go back a couple generations
to like my grandparents' days,
my grandparents were immigrants.
They came over on a boat from Italy and
Ireland.
And when you think about what their life
was like versus what our life is like
today,
I mean we're barely even related.
We're so.
We're so different with our access to
information,
with the understanding that people have
about raising people,
but communicating with people about
talking to yourself.
Even in your reference to going to the
library isn't fantastic.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
Right.
I mean imagine you having that kind of a
conversation with your parents when they
were your age about loving yourself.
Am I being loving myself?
They'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Go out there and farm.
Even I feel that way towards myself
though.
I guess I'm an old soul so I just.
Okay.
I think you're introspective.
So you're looking at yourself,
you know,
mind might in a dark.
Whereas this,
it's more that than anything.
Yeah.
So you're trying to get pregnant.
So.
Yes,
yes.
We actually haven't transferred any of
the embryos.
We've just been collecting them and
they're frozen and we are about to start
the first transfer in the next couple
weeks.
So you'd make it a Frankenstein baby.
That's right.
Science involved.
I know.
I was listening to you and I know you
and Whitney Cummings,
we're talking about that.
Um,
and it is crazy and a weird thing is
that you could have like,
let's say,
of all of our embryos,
two of them are good and will create
babies.
If they happen to be implanted at the
same time,
then I will give birth to twins,
but if not that and we go another round,
then I could have kids,
you know,
a couple of years apart and like that's
what were you,
have you end up doing all this weird
math of like how many should I implant
to maximize the chance of getting
pregnant?
Minimize the chance of multiples.
Um,
I don't know.
It is,
it's weird.
They take your egg and they take your
husband's berm and they mix it up in a
lab somewhere.
Well,
do they do it with lightning bolts and
shit?
They've raised the table up to the.
Yeah,
everything goes dark for a second and
very quiet.
It's,
yeah,
it's exactly like that.
Crazy that they can freeze the embryos.
That's the trickiest one.
And I think normally or I think
traditionally what they do is they take
the eggs and then they take the sperm
and they put it together in a petri dish
and then just kind of let it do its
thing.
But for certain people they do something
called ECC,
which is,
let's see if I can.
It's interests.
Cyto plasma,
my something sperm injection.
So they take the sperm and they
literally inject it and I don't know how
like they must have the tiniest little
needle into the egg.
So it's even more minute.
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy that they can do that
because what if you catch a week load
that way?
Like a week load gets lucky like you,
I would always want the strong
just through the egg to get some.
Well I think that they are using
analysis to,
to uh,
get rid of the weak ones.
They do sperm analysis.
They do have like a,
Oh my God,
that's like the first thing,
like buds camp for sperm in the weak
ones,
they ring the bell,
they take all the sperm they take,
they drive them far into the mountains,
they drop them off,
they give them one peanut and they say,
we'll come back for you in three weeks
and if you're still here,
we're going to inject you into an egg,
give you a Swiss army knife for no
fucking piece of shoestring.
Figured out stupid.
They take away your shoe laces and they
say you have a lot of thinking to do.
Been very bad sperm.
I'm to make a person stupid.
No,
but I get what you're saying in terms of
natural selection.
Ivf is circumventing all of that because
it's taking a whole bunch of women who
are past the age that they can get
pregnant naturally and it's allowing
them to get pregnant.
Yeah,
I mean it is in a way,
but if you make an awesome person that
way,
that's the.
Well,
I mean,
yeah,
there's also that argument which is,
but,
but the people who are doing it are
people who have tried to be responsible
and wait until they're at a point in
life when they can have kids versus like
a 22 or 23 year old who,
and I'm sure there's plenty of great.
Actually I've never met them,
but they're probably out there,
have had kids that young and it all
turned out well.
They can get pregnant pretty easily
usually,
but I don't,
I feel like most early people in their
early twenties aren't really ready to
have kids yet and still like we're
getting emotionally ready later,
but our biology is staying the same
100 percent.
Well that's one of the things that I
always think about when I think about my
mom.
Like my mom had me when she was 21 when
she got pregnant when she was 20 and
when she's 21,
she had a baby when I was 21.
I was a fucking moron.
Yeah.
I can't imagine being forced to raise a
kid when I was 21.
I was so irresponsible.
I couldn't take care of myself and I
think the,
the natural process of people getting
pregnant really young.
I mean like how strange is it with human
beings that you're essentially able to
get pregnant when you're 13.
Right.
That's,
that's crazy.
I just crazy fucking crazy.
So my daughter who is just turned eight,
she's got five years.
She pregnant.
That's insane.
She's a tiny little thing,
a little person,
little baby person,
and like that little baby person can
have a baby inside of them.
That's madness.
It's just our biology is so.
It's so irresponsible now.
It really is.
Yeah,
it's,
uh,
it's just,
it's just such a weird holdover from a
time that we can't even remember when it
made sense to get pregnant at 13.
Well,
yeah,
we can't remember.
But
that's the weirdest thing about biology,
right,
is that the changes that take place
naturally,
they over long periods of time,
hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of years,
but the changes take taking place in our
culture and our society over the last
thousand years has been insane.
The massive amount of difference between
living in 1016 versus 2016 is just you
can't even.
It's there.
It's barely the same life.
Do you think the amount of change that
we have recently is the same amount of
change that had there has always been
historically though?
Or do you feel like things are like
speeding up?
Oh,
they're definitely accelerating.
They're accelerating because of
technology.
One hundred percent that it's just the
world we live in today is alien compared
to the world of a thousand years ago or
even a few hundred years ago.
If you went 200 years ago and showed
them what people,
how people are living today,
they'd be like,
Holy Shit.
Even the crazy science fiction authors,
authors of the 18 hundreds who you know
Jules Verne and you know orson wells and
all these crazy people that had all
these great ideas about the future,
they never thought the Internet.
The Internet is bizarre.
That the idea that it's not going to be
metal spaceships that change us.
It's not going to be laser beams that
were not going to live in the sky,
way crazier than that.
We're gonna live in this one spot,
but everything's going to be there for
you wirelessly and we're all going to be
connected in that way globally
wirelessly.
That's the most fucked up thing.
When I was sitting at home the other day
and somebody sent me a youtube video and
I was watching this crazy youtube video
and as I'm watching Mike,
how bizarre is that?
Someone just sent me something.
I press it and now here I'm watching it
and it's,
it's,
it's playing out in front of me like not
even two seconds after I've got the text
message.
I'm watching this thing.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I was listening to you recently talk
about how you don't think that the human
brain is really like can really knows
how to process celebrity and that's why
we end up putting the Kardashians.
Stop me if I'm putting words in your
mouth,
but like that's why we end up putting
Kardashians on a pedestal or something
because we are biological or biological
historically wired to follow achievement
and success and strength and things like
that,
but then you take people and put them on
TV and turn them into idle,
so to speak,
and it's like that.
Then our,
our,
our lizard brain goes,
oh,
you're someone who has achieved
something.
I should follow you.
I was kinda thinking by the same token,
I don't think that the human brain knows
how to deal with technology information,
the Internet,
all of that because it's like
someone can say something shitty on the
Internet and I don't get that bummed out
by Internet comments anymore,
but there was a time where it's like
some something someone says something
shitty.
My brain doesn't know how to regard that
doesn't know how to put that,
how to prioritize that,
how to see that in perspective.
It just feels like,
oh,
someone close to me.
Is St something Shitty as opposed to
like,
this is
one comment in a sea of comments.
Yeah.
And also one person who you ordinarily
wouldn't be in contact with,
you wouldn't want to hang out with them.
You didn't like them,
they decided to start judging you,
but that's also the flip side of it is
what you can do with your podcast is
reached people that you would never
contact,
reach the world and so you're going to
have people reach back.
It's part of what some people like about
it.
I the ability to comment on something
and somebody that's not valid at all,
like you're going to get criticisms that
are just not valid.
They don't make any sense,
but I and I should say like that level
of connection and that interaction is I
think the best part of it and there is
just this sort of dark side that comes
with that of like,
yeah,
you're going to hear some shit you wish
you hadn't heard.
But for the most part it's amazing.
Yeah,
for the most part,
it's amazing.
The thing that you were talking about
with the Kardashians,
that was something that Neil degrasse
Tyson,
just instagram the other day.
That was a conversation that he and I
had when I did his podcast and I really
firmly believe that,
that there's something about pointing a
camera at someone and putting them on a
screen that you look at them and it
hijacks your reward system,
the reward system that's designed to say
if there's like some,
the,
the mother of this tribe and she's been
alive for a long time and she has all
this wisdom and so when she talks in
front of the fire,
but it's sits down and listens.
Why they listened.
Well,
because she survived.
She's achieved.
She's someone who you have to pay
attention to because she knows things
and you know,
she knows things.
So when she starts talking,
you listen.
That can all be hijacked by a fucking
reality TV show camera on Bravo.
And next thing you know,
it's real housewives.
Some pilled up bitch screaming at her
friend and you know,
like we pay attention to them.
I'm a friend of mine was at the,
um,
one of the people from that real
housewives show has this,
I'm a restaurant.
Is it sir?
And does it have to do with vanderpump
rules,
which I've recently become obsessed with
that lady.
So fucking nuts at vanderbilt are all
nuts.
They're fucking so crazy.
But anyway,
when my friend was at the restaurant,
she said that that lady walked in and
people started losing their shit is
here.
She's here.
She's by why they're at the restaurant.
Yeah.
See here?
Oh yeah.
And then they were freaking out.
They couldn't believe it.
They were getting their phones out there
looking up at her.
I'm like,
this is an incredibly
unexceptional person.
I mean,
she's just nothing about it.
She holds her.
She talks,
she's got restaurants.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like when you're,
when you listening to her talk,
there's nothing that makes you like
compelled to listen to her.
There's no,
like really fascinating words coming out
of her mouth.
She doesn't have any skill.
She's not an artist.
She's a singer.
She's not.
There's nothing there.
Well,
and then you get to the,
they'll sometimes I sort of get stuck in
this eddy of like,
well,
what this
person has created is a very watchable
reality show.
Sure.
Like in terms of content,
Kris Jenner,
look at what she's created,
but I don't know,
but I don't know.
Is that art?
I,
you know,
I don't know.
Well,
we love assholes.
People love watching assholes.
We love people screaming at each other.
We love people sniping at each other.
We love people doing shitty things to
each other.
And we love scenes that last 10 seconds,
10 seconds,
boom.
Cut the next 10 seconds,
Cut to like,
what's happening now?
Oh,
Like they know the exact amount of time.
It's almost like they've got an
algorithm like when to change the camera
scene.
When or when to change the angle.
Have you ever.
I'm going to guess you have not ever
seen vanderpump rules?
No.
I have recently become,
like I said,
sort of addicted to it.
Um,
and at the beginning my husband would be
like,
so what is going on?
He'd wander in like,
what's going on now?
I'm like,
I honestly don't even know.
It's like watching the screen saver I
had in college was just fractals.
It's just watching beautiful Tan people
yell at each other.
It's mesmerizing.
And it kind of is,
it calms me down,
but I'm not,
I'm not really paying attention.
I'm just observing.
Well,
I used to watch the beverly hills
housewife show just to get upset when
you see these pilled up,
ladies yell at each other and then
disappear the bathroom and then they
would go to the bathroom.
She's on pills,
bitch at each other and stuff.
And it was,
uh,
it was,
it was weird.
Like they would try to hurt each other's
feelings on camera.
It was like so obvious.
Yeah,
I know.
Well,
that's another thing is that like
specifically with what,
with all of those shows,
I can feel the producer slightly off
camera feeding them lines and,
and it's like there's this drama that in
real life wouldn't like really,
is that,
are you,
are you really that upset about that?
Because suddenly six people are upset
about something that seems like not a
big deal.
And I feel like that was,
that existed on paper before they did
those scenes.
Well,
more importantly,
your entertainment has been observing
fools.
Like you've put fools on for half an
hour on television.
And that now becomes what focuses,
what were your mind focuses on instead
of something really truly interesting
and enlightening or something
entertaining,
or you're watching fools reluctantly
with this like weird,
guilty feeling like,
what am I doing?
One more one.
And then you realize like these are
people that you would never want to hang
out with in real life and here on this
podcast.
But I hear what you're saying.
But if what's weird is if that was a
drama,
it was a drama.
It was a show and it was all completely
made up.
It wouldn't be nearly as interesting
because the narratives are really
boring.
It's like we're going to go get shoes.
We're going to go down this journey
together and Debbie needs to.
She doesn't think she needs shoes,
but I'm telling her she needs fucking
shoes.
Accumulation chosen those shoes.
I would not wear those shoes,
but I'm not going to tell her that.
And
there's one girl who just says what's on
her mind.
She people think she's a bitch,
but she just keeps it real.
She keeps it real.
She speaks her mind.
I'm just gonna.
Keep it real.
Keep it real and know you have these.
She says what everyone else is afraid to
say except for the six other people who
are also saying that we all think it,
but we won't say it and she's the one
that says it should go right in your
face.
She doesn't care.
She doesn't care and Stephanie for you.
But I know a couple of those people in
real life like from the show,
from real housewives of Beverly Hills
and they're really sad,
really depressed and really sad and the
blowback from being on that show is
atrocious.
Like their social media blowback that
they read the comments and there they
get devastated.
Like,
do you remember when Kelsey grammer's
wife was on that show for one fucking
season?
And she tried to like,
be like some.
She tried to really play it up like she
was fucking,
Hey,
don't wave the tsunami of hate.
Well that's the thing.
I think that kind of happens from what
you're saying about like we're watching
fools is you're nine.
You're not like,
I'm watching a great piece of art or
something.
You know,
we're watching you.
You watch it with this idea that you're
somehow better than the people you're
watching.
So I think it's like they become
punching bags and that must suck.
Oh,
it's got.
It has to suck because we'll Kelsey
grammar of course and her or getting a
divorce and before they got a divorce
she got on the show and when she got on
the show it was like really weird stuff.
Like she was hanging out with like
actors and hopping on the motorcycle
with them and he's my friend and they
drive a good looking guy,
a fucking great hair and Kelsey
grammer's fat and gross and she's riding
off.
She's Kinda hot and she used to be in
playboy.
So the whole thing was like,
what is going on here?
And she just had this crazy fucking
shitty attitude and was flaunting it in
front of all these people's face.
But the thing is I had met her before
that and she wasn't really like that at
all.
It was her reality show.
It's this thing they do.
They feel like they have to like play it
up.
And then I met her.
I saw her at a party in the middle of
that Shell,
like when the hate was coming down and
she looked like the weight of the
fucking world was weighing on her like
when she was walking,
because so many people hated her.
And then she got off the show.
She was like,
fuck this.
Like she was very smart in that way.
But Kelsey grammer had some interview
where he did.
He said that's what she always wanted.
So I gave her what she wanted and I knew
she wasn't even really want it,
but she always said she always wanted
because that was the whole thing.
Like she had this little video that you
did at the beginning of the show and the
beginning of his,
uh,
you know,
I've always been in Kelsey's shadow,
but it's time for me to step out of all
those shows.
The world know who I am,
letting my star shine.
You know,
one of those things.
And the fucking just the green monster
of hate that descended upon her.
You could feel it.
And I know a couple of those people that
are on that show and that overwhelming
negative message that you put out by
being that person and the response to
millions of people hating you,
like literally millions of people
saying you're a dumb cunt,
like it's devastating.
It's devastating because the people
directly respond to whatever message
that you're putting out there.
And that message is compelling that that
fucking Beverly Hills housewives,
bitchy message.
I'm going to personify that low petty,
craven bitchiness that probably exists
in all human beings.
I'm going to be the embodiment of it.
You think that that like in terms of put
what you put out in the universities,
brings it back to them.
I don't think it's a distraction
obviously.
Right?
Those shows are a distraction.
Like all shows.
I mean you could say that about great
shows like game of thrones.
It's a distraction.
Ultimately it's entertaining and what
does entertaining.
You're sitting there and you're
pretending these things are happening
and you get to just go off with them.
You get to go.
But there's something different about,
you know that Tyrian lannister isn't
really Tyrian lannister when you see
these people,
this is them,
this is their actual face is their
clothes.
They were,
this is them talking to these other
people.
There's cameras on them.
So it's this bizarre distortion of what
is,
what is reality.
And also it's been real clear.
There's a formula that's been
established where if you can be the
bitch on the show that makes a lot of
noise and you know,
you could,
you could keep it real and speak your
mind.
That girl gets a lot of potentials.
You can get a daytime talk show.
And when that girl gets a lot of
attention,
they keep the camera on her.
When they keep the camera on her,
the other girls go,
that fucking bitches get all this camera
time.
Like I know a couple of those girls that
are outside of it and they'll,
they'll bitch that the,
you know,
brandy,
this and that,
and now that's why they're fucking
paying attention to her.
But that fucking bitch and blah blah
blah.
So they get the ramp it up,
they'll ramp up there like,
like I've decided that this season I'm
going to be more bitchy or I'm this
season,
I'm gonna,
you know,
I'm going to be more forceful because
I've just,
I've sat back,
I'm not gonna let them edit me because
they edit me,
you know,
I know what they're doing.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm not going to
give them anything to edit everything
they do.
I'm going to fucking hit him like this.
This is how I feel on it.
He get caught up in this whole wave of
crazy.
Right?
If trying to manipulate the
manipulators.
Yeah.
And then you see it in their faces.
They're just popping pills and drink it
all the time and,
and,
and you know,
dealing with what they asked for.
They wanted this fame and so they get
it.
But then the also get
the hate part.
Have you seen,
you know,
a lot of famous people in general?
Have you seen anyone enjoy fame?
Because I feel like my,
what I,
from what I've seen it become,
it's a thing that people have to learn
to manage,
but it's not,
it's never what they thought it was
going to be.
Kevin Hart doesn't seem to have a
problem with it.
Kevin Harts and interesting guy because
he is a super positive,
super positive,
super motivated.
Even people shit on him.
He doesn't shit on them back.
Like he'll goof around with some comics
that will go after him.
He'll,
he'll mock them and make fun of them.
But he's always laughing,
you know,
he's a really,
really,
really ambitious guy.
So I think like his level of like what
he's looking for,
this
is just part of the equation.
And he just keeps going.
I keep wanting to be like an oprah.
He wants to be a mogul,
you know,
his,
his goal.
So He seems to be handling it better
than anybody I've ever met.
But for most people,
I think we all agree like we've had
conversations about it.
Um,
I've had a conversation about it with a
bunch of different celebrities.
And one thing that everybody seems to
agree,
if you don't want to ever get as famous
as Tom Cruise,
there's like a level of fame you don't
want to hit,
you don't want to be Brad Pitt.
Like a buddy of mine is friends with
Johnny Depp and he says,
Johnny Depp can't go anywhere like the.
He hangs out with them.
There's these guys with earpieces that
follow them everywhere.
And they were in London staying at
Johnny Depp's house and he went to step
outside to go get some cigarettes and he
walks outside and there's these guys
standing there with earpieces on,
do you need a ride?
Do you need to take you anywhere?
And it's like,
this guy can't go anywhere.
He goes to a restaurant that he goes to
a restaurant and they swarm on him.
They swarm on him.
Whereas some people can go to a
restaurant and they can look over there,
go,
oh,
that's doug stanhope.
I look overall that's ron white and it's
they're famous,
but they're not.
It's not a crazy thing to see them.
Here's a perfect example.
Me and Kevin James,
we're filming a movie.
We were in Boston and we were hanging
out in his hotel and we're,
we're joking around and laughing and out
the window looking in front of this
restaurant.
Tom Cruise was at this restaurant and we
looked out the window.
We saw Tom Cruise,
we see people taking pictures of Tom
Cruise and then we see people on the
street running towards the restaurant of
fucking running,
like running because they heard that Tom
cruise there and we're watching this and
you know the glasses right here.
We're pressing up against the grass
glass so we can look at an angle and I
stopped and I go,
how crazy is I go?
Here you are.
You're a movie star and you're like
craning your neck to try to get a
glimpse at Tom Cruise on the street at a
restaurant across the street from.
You can't queens right there.
He's,
but he's that famous,
that famous people freak out when he's
around like he's way too famous.
He's hit some weird,
bizarre level.
Doesn't make any sense.
It's also weird that people do that and
not saying I'm not.
One of them was,
do you want to be in movies?
You mean you want to be.
If you want to be a superstar and you
want to be in those gigantic
blockbusters that happens,
it can happen.
It doesn't happen to a lot of people,
but for every Samuel Jackson,
there's 100 dudes who try to be like
that for every.
But for Tom Cruise like that is like as
famous as a person fucking gets in
America at least there's no more famous
person than that guy.
So when you see that it's compelling and
some sort of strange way.
Even for a movie star like Kevin James,
he's a fucking famous guy.
He's filming a movie starring in the
movie,
looking out the window.
Can't believe you can Tom Cruise.
It's weird celebrity in some way.
It's like currency
and I don't mean for the person who is
the celebrity.
I mean for the.
For the the person who you're like,
I am seeing something that most people
don't get to see.
Most people only see in terms of most
people's relationship with Tom Cruise.
You see cocktail on top gun and all his
most recent films that I'm not naming
because I don't know them,
um,
excuse me,
but here you are.
Just seeing him at a restaurant.
Like that's something that most people
don't get to see the rarity or the
scarcity of it.
Um,
you know,
what else I was thinking in terms of
what it does to our brain.
When you see someone's face,
that's a huge.
And you're,
you know,
when you're sitting in a darkened
theater and someone's fake faces 50,
50 feet tall,
that kind of replicates the way your
parents and all adults appear to you
when you're a baby.
It's a baby or just sitting there and
there's these faces.
They're huge and they show up and there
are over you and then they're gone.
And I don't know,
do you know that that's what a lot of
psychologist believe,
or the origins of alien abduction
memories.
I did not know that they believed the
origins of alien abduction memories have
to do with birth.
And that's why that clinical strange
setting of being pulled out of your
mother's womb,
of seeing the light of those in this
really white sterile environment that
seems cold and harsh and the people with
the masks on surgical masks and big eyes
that you see these things and they
become iconic in your head and you,
you think of them in,
not in terms of like a person with a
mask on,
but in terms of this like very strange
distortion of reality and these are the
first images that a person has.
That's interesting.
A human brain when they're a baby is
very,
very tiny,
but obviously it's still a human brain
and so we don't really know how much
data they store in terms of memories
because we don't have a context.
Like they can't talk about it.
They can't mean people.
Some people will claim that they have
certain memories from early childhood
and they might be.
It might be correct,
but it also might be some sort of a.
A rehashing of memories to the point
where it's not really a memory.
Just for a minute,
you've heard what's a memory?
It's remembering how to describe a
memory you once had like the memory
itself probably doesn't exist anymore.
You have a memory of how you told the
memory and that like really sort of
distorts it too,
but it think of like visually you've
never seen anything.
You've been in a womb and then all of a
sudden you get pulled out and you get
pulled out by a guy with a fucking giant
light behind him and he's got a mask on
and he's looking at you and you pull it
all.
You see his eyes and his face and so
that they believed that gets distorted
into this iconic giant head,
black giant eyes and the the cold sort
of clinicals,
antiseptic room,
this white room with the light.
That's why everyone has these abduction
scenarios.
They all deal with medical exams that
are pretty preposterous.
I mean,
they're always going up your butt with
stuff and I think that's right where the
aliens go.
Yeah.
I think that has to do with.
I think it's vulnerability because like
you think about your button like,
Hey,
get out of there.
You know,
like everybody thinks like that.
Right,
so I think that's the one thing you'd be
terrified of if the aliens had ultimate
control over you.
If you couldn't move your body and they
take,
what are they gonna do?
They're gonna talk to my body.
Yeah,
it's going to go inside my body are
going into my,
but like,
you know what I mean?
Was like,
I think that that really makes a lot of
sense.
That's.
I'd never heard that before,
but that's really interesting.
That does make sense.
Yeah.
How good your eyes work and then when
you come out of your mother not that.
Well now everything's hazy.
Everything's hazy and weird in the
light.
Also,
you've never seen light before,
so seeing this extreme light as powerful
light source because everything has to
be really bright so you could really get
a good look at everything and make sure
you're stitching up the badge.
Good.
No.
And getting in there and looking at the
baby and making sure everything's in
place and then putting that baby in an
incubator like whoa.
If you're a boy,
some oftentimes circumcising,
they don't do it right there.
Now I guess they wait a few days,
still do that.
God,
I get.
I get text messages or tweets all the
time from people that support my stance
on circumcision.
I think it's barbaric.
I do too.
It's creepy.
It's crazy.
The idea that people necessary nowadays
a hundred percent.
Sorry.
There's this nonsense that it somehow or
another prevents.
It's like,
get the fuck out of here.
There's no data.
Zero.
If you go look at the actual studies
that try to back it up,
they'll talk about it in third world
countries like there's still no data.
You can't tell me that you all couldn't
be the same exact result.
Couldn't be cleaning your Dick.
How about just clean your deck and
they'll cut a baby's deck.
I know because the amount of pain that I
think that maybe must feel,
oh well it's.
It's also,
it's traumatic.
It's like you're taking away like a
certain amount of the child's freedom
and decision making,
like really early on and you're.
You're cutting them there.
Cut It for no reason.
Just screaming that in.
A lot of babies lose their decks.
By the way.
Super Common Infections,
really common babies,
babies die from it.
I mean it's not like one has ever died
from it.
A bunch died and there's a real problem
with traditional Jewish methods because
the moyal actual actually sucks on the
penis.
I'm not making any of this right now.
I'm just saying it's,
it's disgusting and they transfer herpes
to the baby sometimes and the babies die
and it's not just one but many babies
have died from getting herpes from a
rabbi sucking on the baby's penis.
Yeah.
I was watching this youtube video wants
of this guy defending this practice and
he was a,
you know,
an old rabbi and it was talking about
how,
you know,
it's in the faith and if you believe in
God and God came up with it the right
way and this is
so.
I don't understand the link between
cutting a piece of for skin or cutting
the forest skin and God like I don't.
That doesn't work.
I'm not religious person in general,
so these things often don't link up in
my head,
but it's like how I don't,
I just don't get it.
How does that have anything to do with
God?
It's an ancient shit.
It's back when people were stupid as
fuck.
You know of any data.
It's really.
What is it?
I want to think that we are just as
stupid now as we were then.
No,
yeah,
no,
we're not.
We're not.
We're not as stupid as people who live
in the 19 twenties watch.
Try to watch a movie from like 1940 and
watch out.
Dopey people were.
It was like God.
Everyone was so dumb.
Like it's like they didn't even know how
to be in color.
There were sad.
There were so strange and childlike and
a lot of ways like,
and you know,
the other thing is people just,
they didn't have the access to
information.
They didn't live as long and they didn't
have anybody around them that had access
to information the way they do.
You do for every scholar and every
person who is deeply embedded in
intellectual pursuits.
You had millions and millions of people
that just didn't give a fuck and we're
just trying to get by.
So you,
I cut you off.
You were saying that you were watching,
um,
a rabbi talk about the importance of
circumcision
to portions of circumcision and doing it
the traditional way where you suck on
the baby's penis and it was talking
about that there's antiseptic properties
and saliva and it helps stop the
bleeding.
Like,
fuck,
you just don't cause the bleeding.
Just out to stop.
I was so furious watching this asshole
dress like a wizard.
Talk about sucking on baby Dick's after
they caught them.
I just wanted to beat the fuck out of
them are really dead.
It's just like watching.
I was like,
you make me so angry with your stupid
thinking that you're justifying cutting
a baby's deck and you're talking about
some dumb ass old ancient bullshit there
was written by morons who thought the
world was flat and you,
you,
you want to continue that in 2016
because it's tradition.
It's like it makes me mad.
It makes me really mad because you're
talking about fucking babies.
If you're a grown adult and you get
sucked into some stupid cult that wants
to cut your Dick and I let that old dude
suck on it.
All right man.
How old are you?
Thirty five.
Good light.
Don't do it.
I'd say don't do it,
but good luck,
but when you do it to a baby,
it just makes me fucking furious and you
see this guy you just see in cloaking
himself in tradition and using it to
justify these like objectively barbaric
practices.
If you stand back and look at it like a
analyzing,
like what?
What benefit is there?
What?
What are the.
What are the risks and what's the
consequences on what are we doing here?
You sucking on a baby's Dick Dude,
you talking about sucking baby decks?
What?
How has that.
How has it real?
Like how is that guy not in jail?
How does that exist in this modern
world?
Imagine though,
if he wasn't in a religion where imagine
if he just liked cutting baby dixon and
sucking on them.
You'd fucking have him killed.
But the fact that he can do that,
he can be regarded as an elder and a
scholar and he's got crazy robes on and
shit.
He's got like a like gilded gold around
the stupid fucking outfit that he's
wearing.
And I'm like,
Oh my God,
you fool.
Are you angry that you were circumcised,
assuming you were?
No,
because my deck looks perfect.
I,
if I had a chance to do it over again,
I would definitely say don't do that.
But no,
it doesn't make me angry.
It's not that I can do about it,
but it's just a foolhardy practice.
It's just,
it doesn't,
it doesn't help anybody.
It sounded like it.
Imagine if there was like an improvement
that you can make,
you know,
like everybody was born unfortunately
with this flap of skin on their
forehead.
But if you remove that flap of skin,
you know,
you can read people's minds,
oh my God,
Oh yeah,
I'd take that flap of skin off.
Let's read each other's minds.
It'd be amazing.
They found out a hack.
There's like a biohack,
but that's not it.
It doesn't.
It didn't.
In fact,
it,
it lessens the pleasure.
It changes the way your penis feels.
Allegedly,
I wouldn't know,
but that's what they say.
There's a whole group of people that
work to bring their for skin back.
How do you do that?
That was apparently that you stretched
the skin slowly over time until it
regenerates a for skin it had never had.
That was possible.
Yeah,
that's about it never general
regenerates a real force skin because
it's always going to be folded over and
some sort of a strange way,
but the reaction is that it be it
reignites or re whatever it is,
the mucus membranes.
So you're the tip of your penis.
Sorry to get graphic folks.
It's supposed to have like almost like a
liquid mucusy sort of membrane over it.
That's all dried out.
Now.
When dudes get circumcised,
so desensitizes your penis and when your
penis is encased in skin and the is
pulled back,
it's much more sensitive and supposedly
much more pleasurable.
Know who knows if that was a part of the
reason why they started doing it in the
first place or if it was a hygiene issue
at the time.
People didn't know that much about
washing.
Who knows?
What was the initial urge?
You know,
Mitch,
I'm sure it's under debate,
but did you see the headlines yesterday
about how science has.
They've,
they've developed this some sub second
skin,
second skin for that.
Yeah,
I guess.
but that seems like it would actually do
the opposite.
Well,
maybe if you kept it on every day.
I guess you're right.
I think if you kept it on everyday,
what the thing about that second skin
though that's interesting is that
they're,
they think that they're going to be able
to use it for medication,
like for people that have psoriasis or
Eczema,
they can put medication on and then put
that second skin on second skin will
actually hold the medication in place.
He has a second skin things.
That trip I was watching,
they did it to this old lady's face and
it just sucked it back in or bags under
my eyes,
like normal,
a seminar.
It's invisible.
It's really weird line for your face,
but better because you can kind of see
invisalign.
It's going to change the way people's
faces look,
but the people that did the Joan rivers
thing that just filled their face up
with rubber and stretched it all out
there fucked.
They're fucked.
Like all the early adopters of surgery
and fillers and all that craziness that
people have done to their lips and
there's this lady that I know,
I don't call her monster face to face,
but
she's a type of look that I call monster
face.
A lot of women have it.
Yeah,
but that monster face thing,
what happens is they stretch their face
out so much that their mouth is way too
big.
Like their lips go way over here.
You're not supposed to go over here,
but they're doing this because they're
just pulling it up.
They're pulling a face back so much that
when they.
When they smile and they open their
mouth,
you start doing the FIBONACCI sequence
in your mind and you go,
something's wrong because there's a
natural,
like your nose,
the correct size for your eyes and your
lips and your chin and your face and we
all have like,
there's a symmetry to it,
a human face and there's a sequence that
the fibonacci sequence you can actually
calculate it.
FIBONACCI had to do with facial features
and stuff.
I've heard a FIBONACCI but I didn't
realize it has to do with a lot of
different features that exist in nature.
Like pine cones,
nautilus shells.
I've heard it used when I'm.
So I used to play in a band and so when
my friends tend to recording studios and
I know that it was used to like figure
out acoustic nodes,
I think some,
some pattern of sound waves.
Well tool did a whole song with the
fibonacci sequence,
you know,
they,
um,
they figured out a way to incorporate
the sequence into the way the lyrics are
structured and the way that the beats
are structured.
But there's,
when you,
the ratio of a person's face gets
distorted with plastic surgery and it's
one of the things that's upsetting when
you see someone they've got like crazy
fake lips,
like Whoa,
what's going on with your lips,
you know,
or whatever,
or knows what is going on with her.
So I think that when we change things,
what does this jamie sequence and
natural.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So it's showing the um,
the sequence as applied to the human
face,
but it's applied to everything
apparently.
But I think when you see it as pretty
cool and see it sunflowers when you see
it in,
um,
in human faces after surgery,
I think that's one of the reasons why
there's like an automatic,
like repelling response.
Like it pulls you back.
Like,
Whoa,
what I wonder is because I feel like I'm
really good at spotting plastic surgery,
but I wonder how many people walked by
and I don't like people who have good
plastic
surgery where you just don't notice it
and you just think they're attractive.
Like that must exist.
There's definitely some subtle prostate
surgery that they've done really well.
Like there's some subtle facelifts and
some things along those lines that uh,
another person I know,
I know this lady,
she's like 60 and she looks hot.
It's pretty hot and she's had a gang of
shit done.
Maybe too much.
Like she may be like a obsesses a little
bit nips and tucks.
But you look at her,
you're like,
God damn,
she's 60.
Like she looks really good.
She but you know,
they do a little of this,
a little desk.
But then I know monster face and you
know,
she's got a mouth.
It looks like a good eat a baby's head.
Like she,
she just looks like a monster.
Like her cheeks are huge.
Is she happy with how she looks at you?
The fuck knows.
I don't know her that well,
but are actually this girl stopped up
with rubber.
They do weird stuff where it looks like
they just had mouth surgery where their
jaws are swollen because they feel like
so much puffing out their face.
Remove some of the wrinkles.
I see.
So it was funny in a town that prizes
being skinny so much.
I see so many people.
Men to have these like balloony faces
because there is just filled with,
I don't know if it's botox or juvederm.
I don't know.
I.
I have not had any of that done,
so I don't really know,
but it's like,
yeah,
their faces.
It looks like it looks like they're
puffing them out.
It will look.
So there's.
They're filled with irritant is what it
is.
Yeah.
Well there's an actual physical
substance in there that's making their
face thicker to get rid of the lines.
Yeah.
All that stuff is going to go away.
They're.
They're on the verge of releasing.
There's a guy in Germany that created
this procedure called Regena keen and
Regena keen is they take your blood,
they spin it in a centrifuge and the
heated up and then they take the.
There's like a yellow serum that gets
developed in your blood and it's a
direct response to the heat.
Your.
Your body reacts as if it's in a flu and
it produces these radical
antiinflammatories.
They take these inflammatories and they
inject it into injured areas and all
these athletes like coby
Brianne.
It's crazy.
I just read about this,
the wonderful athlete.
Kim Kardashians did it.
They call it a plasma facial.
Okay.
That's different.
That's still a blood in a centrifuge and
then heated
up.
That's um,
that's um,
a bullshit.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's a type of plasma.
Um,
fuck.
What was it called?
Um,
I forget what they're called,
but it's similar.
It's similar.
I forget the,
the procedures named something.
Plasma.
Fucking God damn it.
Why don't I not remember this?
Anyway,
it's similar but not the same.
This regena king thing involves heat and
in devolves your blood's response to the
heat and then taking that serum and
injecting it back by point being that
same doctor that created this procedure
created a new procedure that restarts
the body's production of Collagen.
So what wrinkles are,
is your body loses its elasticity and it
starts to give in and starts to get
sloppy and loose.
And that's why people get facelifts.
Well,
with his new procedure,
he's going to restart your body's
production of Collagen.
You're going to develop college and like
a 20 year old.
Wow.
Which is fucking freaky because that's
all it is.
It's not,
it's not something like you're asking
people to,
you know,
be able to jump 10 feet higher,
you like,
it's not insurmountable.
It's just a simple matter of the body
not producing as much as something that
it used to produce.
So they figured out a way to get it to
do.
So instead of pulling your face back and
stuffing it with rubber and all that
stuff.
Are there health benefits to that?
Or is that just vanity?
Because like you know earlier we were
talking about that is,
is being in the gym all the time about
vanity.
I would say if you're 80 and you need to
look 20,
that's vanity.
I mean ask me when I'm 80,
but it's like why does everyone need to
look?
So you look better when you're 20
so if you want to look better,
do it.
It's really simple.
Is it vanity?
Well there's a vanity.
When you cut your hair,
is it vanity?
When you wear nice clothes?
The vanity,
when you wash your face,
when you were making.
I think about especially used to think
about that all the time because I really
wanted a nose job for the longest time.
I never got one.
Sometimes I still
need to do that.
You have a beautiful nose.
Thank you.
Um,
that's a mind.
Fuck,
wait,
what is a mind fuck?
What's wrong with my nose?
And my fear is always like,
well,
what if I end up with some stupid tiny
nose that doesn't look right on my face
and then I can't get it back.
And plus I feel like that's just,
that's just going too far.
But then I think.
But you know,
I had braces so my teeth looked
different than they would have looked
otherwise.
And I straightened my hair and I looked
better with straight hair.
I looked better with straight teeth.
I like all these little things.
So why is that one different?
And it just is because it involves,
you know,
undergoing a procedure and I sort of
don't.
Well here's the thing,
I don't agree with doing it,
but still it's like where do you draw
the line?
If you were born with a weird hump on
your nose and they straightened that out
and all of a sudden you're a beautiful.
Yeah.
That can happen.
I mean,
there's people that.
Why don't we?
Why is that?
Okay,
but just a nip tuck we've decided is
not.
Well,
it's not that it's not okay.
You can do whatever the fuck you want,
but it's a rabbit hole.
If you.
If you go down that I want to get a nose
job,
rabbit hole,
you might go.
I think my eyebrows be better if there
were an inch.
Oh,
are you saying there would be no,
but you know,
you'd be like,
well that's the argument against a way
to make my lips just a little tucker
this on that.
Listen to this.
I want this tiny little.
That's what stops me from starting any
of that is that I don't want to be
monster faced because it's so easy to go
like,
oh yeah,
you know,
my upper lip is not as full as my lower
lip.
Maybe I could change that or like I feel
like I'm beginning to get lines here.
Maybe I could do something,
you know,
like there's all those
sections in there at some filler in just
bucket from a little fat around the
outside of my lips,
but I don't have the wrinkles will be
happy or like,
hey,
maybe some of this fat can we moved
here.
Next thing you know there's an alien up
your butt.
Will help.
Helps people take some of the fat,
other inner thigh only injected in their
ass and I'll sign it.
Looks like they're wearing a diaper.
I know a lady went that done about that.
Are you hanging out with
white people?
Live all this older white people with
money.
They just panic and start sticking stuff
in their body,
but she looks like she's wearing a
diaper.
She's got these little popsicle legs
like she doesn't know.
She unhappy with her flat,
but before I don't know that well know
that she had some stuff injecting her
ass.
She's not.
The only one I know is don't either.
I know quite a few people have done it.
It's a bizarre practice.
There's our.
Are you familiar with waist training?
I only learned about this recently.
That's another crazy thing,
but I was at the grocery store and I saw
this woman with this gigantic ass
gigantic thighs,
like big,
tiny,
tiny little waist.
I was so turned on.
No,
it was very unnatural
gang.
A friend of mine got with this girl once
and they hooked up and they got together
and start fooling around and she had a
thick waste and it freaked him out.
She said,
he said that she was boxy.
He said she went from her shoulder down
to her hips and it was a straight line
and I was like,
wow.
Freaked you out.
Like how it goes.
I just,
I had to leave.
I go,
what the geometry of your body like the
fact that it didn't go.
I go,
she's pretty,
and he goes,
I never met the girl.
I go,
she's pretty.
He goes,
yeah,
she's beautiful.
I go,
hold on.
She's beautiful,
but her body was too square.
Did you notice that before you got
together?
He goes,
I didn't think it would be a big deal,
but when we got together it was a big
deal and I'm like,
Whoa,
well yeah.
At least he's trying to look at the
things that really matter.
Um.
What kind of woman does your friend
normally?
I'm sorry,
I'm being so fucking judgment hungry
artist side instead of just being like a
nose job or braces or something.
It's one thing like the boxy body,
like this fucking piece of shit.
Like,
well,
you know why?
Because I walk around with like,
there's like 19 things about me.
I'm not into,
but I'm like,
oh,
whatever.
People won't notice.
And then like I never even thought of
the level of boxiness of a body being
something.
I mean I'm married so I'm not out there
trying to impress people with my body.
Not Be boxy.
I can be boxy.
I've got that freedom,
but I'm just saying I didn't know I
needed to worry about that.
Well you don't need to worry about it
unless you were hanging out with my
retarded friend.
But if you were,
well is he retarded when definitely
retarded comes to that kind of stuff.
He's retarded when comes to everything.
Oh,
okay.
But I was just amazed that he left this
girl's place because she had a boxy body
was.
I mean,
would he have had sex with her?
Otherwise he would have stuck it in the
boxes box.
The boxes box.
Yes.
It's like that joke could have come off
better.
The execution invite me back some day
and I'm only going to have that one.
Perfect.
It is our first go at it.
I'll have a different face by then,
but that joke will pretend to ignore it.
Yeah.
I remember I was in the Irvine Improv.
No,
Bray Bray Improv.
We're in the green room and we're
waiting to go on.
And we were just barbecued high,
like really,
really stoned and was watching TV and it
was comedy central was on comedy
central,
one of those shows where,
um,
uh,
before she died,
um,
her name,
Joan Rivers,
Joan rivers had full on rubber face and
she was on the screen.
And when you're really high,
things like that,
just,
they just glaring stand out.
And I,
and I just go and I just held my hand up
to my face,
like the home alone kid.
I was like,
oh no.
Oh No.
Like what is going on here?
I count was anybody how.
How was just like letting this go on was
how come someone doesn't step in and go,
what the fuck you doing?
You can do this.
This is crazy.
Her whole head was just rubber and
inflated.
Nothing was moving,
nothing was moving.
The forehead wasn't moving,
the cheeks weren't moving.
I'm like,
Whoa,
this is a total new kind of face that
never existed before,
that we see on tv all the time.
That always shocks me or frightens me.
That idea that what if I couldn't have
an expressions?
Yeah.
What if couldn't do this?
I can't do that.
You can't.
But that's so important.
I think that's so important for.
If you're going to be on camera,
having a face that displays emotion is
important.
So why would you want to humble yourself
to that degree?
That's really interesting.
You brought this up because I was
watching boxing this weekend and Canelo
Alvarez fought Amir Khan and I'm,
they're doing this thing now in boxing.
It's really weird.
Where when the,
um,
post-fight ring announcer is
interviewing the fighters.
Who is Max Kellerman who is interviewing
the fighter.
She's asking these questions.
They have these girls stand right there.
These really pretty girls like,
stand for like,
like as if they're his friends and they
stand right next to them and it's so
fucking distracting.
And this one girl,
I don't know if she has botox or for
faces just naturally shiny.
She looks like really young.
Like I don't think she has botox,
but she's just sitting there like a
smile,
like half expression and she probably
can move her face.
It's probably all in my head,
but all I'm thinking of is fucking heads
frozen.
The Fred's,
she's only,
she could have had 29 years old.
Yeah.
Isn't racism.
People do Botox now,
but that's how bold vanderpump rules.
Sorry to bring it up again.
Why would they do that?
If their face is not wrinkled?
Apparently according to one of the guys,
it's,
it's a preventative.
They're getting interviewed.
See the girl behind him.
She's very pretty beautiful girl.
Her fucking forehead hasn't moved in
months.
That God damn thing is frozen.
Face looks.
Plastic does it.
To me.
It was pretty hot seat.
That's a certain amount of plastic I'll
tolerate,
but it's just.
It was freaking me out.
I was like,
why is there a wiser skin frozen?
Is that just seeing her in the back?
It's hard to tell,
but it was like there's like a shyness
to foreheads when they do that shit.
Like there's like an artificial shyness
to it.
It's like it's pull.
It's not even that it's pulled back,
but he was zapped.
It,
zapped it and froze it.
A little tiny micro muscular.
Things aren't happening and it's
paralyzed.
Botulism.
I know you're injecting botulism in your
fucking face to keep it from moving.
You're paralyzing your face.
I know lady who did it and it went bad.
She got a cheap one done and our eye
droop down like those six weeks.
Yeah,
six weeks later for six weeks it looked
like fucking Arturo Gotti was like.
It was like somebody had been beating on
her with Jabs.
Yeah,
I know.
If someone has a side of her mouth and
she was a newscaster side of my mouth,
drooped her tail.
When it came back,
what did she do?
So the newscast,
she.
I don't know if she went on.
I only.
I heard about it from other people.
I'm sure she was freaking out about it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Fucking what a weird problem to have.
I injected too much botulism in the side
of my face and now I drool when I eat.
That's what honestly scares me about all
that stuff is the idea of something
going wrong that is don't trust anyone
enough to let them do that.
We'll also those when they inject the
botulism,
there's like a lot of different levels
of people that are good at it and Shitty
at it and some people they,
you know,
there's people that think more is
better,
so more of that stuff in there and just
freeze the whole fucking thing.
People do it to their arms.
Did you know that?
They do it to different parts of their
body.
I recently heard though about how it can
be a migraine care and that makes sense.
Thirty nine tiny injections in different
places in your head and it helps with
migraines.
That kind of makes sense.
If migraines or pressure and pressure is
caused by tension released those
tension.
So what?
What do people do when they put it in
their arms or why people don't want the
way their elbows looking shit.
Oh,
that's different jamie.
That's.
Yeah,
that's all.
We'll see what that guy that's.
Those are not real muscles.
That's something called we're looking.
We're looking at a video or an image of
a guy who's on something called Synthol
and Synthol is something that people who
were into bodybuilding do where they
inject it into their muscles and it's
oil that inflates the size of the
muscle,
doesn't change the strength of the
but it makes your muscles like blow up
and look completely.
That guy with the red tee shirt.
I'll
look at these guys like,
look at this.
They've.
They inject their muscles and make them
fucking enormous and not just a little
bigger way bigger than normal.
Like it's madness.
Okay.
Well it doesn't look real at all.
It's crazy,
but it's a form of body dysmorphia where
these guys think it looks good.
You know?
It's like when a girl gets size 78,
double e tents,
they get crazy.
They just start,
start thinking that that's the way to go
and it never looks big enough for them
and they just want to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and it's like
anorexics bodybuilders body dysmorphia
is a real thing.
It's like,
well you were saying like looking at
your own known and she's like,
I just changed this and do something
with it and just start finding.
You stare at it long enough.
You start finding things you don't like
about it.
You start,
you just go through the looking glass
and he gets everything gets distorted.
Hi kind of thing almost.
I've,
I,
it really seems that almost all women
have a certain amount of body
dysmorphia.
I know I certainly do,
especially having been pretty overweight
and then now whatever I am and then,
you know,
it's like I don't,
I don't know how to regard myself in the
mirror and by the way,
I don't need anyone to tell me how to
regard myself unless it's positive.
Well,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well I just realized I was sort of
inviting,
inviting some stuff and I thank you.
But no thank you.
Um,
but yeah,
I just,
most women in this culture don't really
have a sense of what
they look like.
Well,
I think there's also an issue with
improvement in general,
whereas you,
I think that that also can be applied to
people that just get way too rich and
way too successful.
It can be applied to looking at your own
body,
looking at your mind,
looking at your face,
your face in particular.
Like there's,
you can,
you can improve the way you look,
right?
You can wear makeup,
you can change your hairstyle and when,
when you can do something you're always
never sure when you're done.
Yeah,
so like if you're making a painting,
how hard is it to make a painting and
walk away like,
okay,
that's good.
No,
I'm just going a little more and this
process of improvement,
you can get caught up in it where you
lose your objectivity and you can't see
it the way other people can see it and I
think that is a big part of what body
dysmorphia is.
You just factionism yeah,
you,
we,
we have this desire to improve things,
right?
You have design.
I think I'm going to renovate my house.
The next thing you know,
you're going fucking crazy and tearing
walls down and rewiring things and like,
what?
What is that?
Well,
what are you doing right now?
It's like this thing where you can't
just appreciate,
you have to like constantly change
things and if,
if that's applied to your face,
you know,
or your waste with the waste training
that you're about to get into that where
they were,
those corsets and soc themselves in and
compress their organs and also hinder
organ function.
You know,
it can fuck with the way your,
because you're not.
Everything is not fucking jammed in
light that you can change the shape of
your organs.
You know,
it's this soft tissue.
Have you wear a corset enough?
I saw a guy with the course of the other
day where,
well,
I'm assuming he was a guy because he had
a beard,
but in this day and age and not allowed
to assume that anymore,
uh,
he was at universal universal citywalk
or a city park,
you know,
the fucking,
the rides and he had a pink corset on
and birkenstocks.
It was,
it was a dude
such mixed messages because the
birkenstocks are like,
I'm going to just be comfortable.
The course that's like,
no,
I'm not.
I think his message was this is how he
likes to dress,
you know,
but it was a pink corset and it was
stuffed into this thing and then he had
like,
you know,
wacky hair and a beard and like kind of
women.
He close kind of some,
some parts of the clothing he was
wearing were women's law.
Yeah.
That the,
the shirt as well as a woman's shirt was
very odd.
Just sounds like an uncomfortable
ensemble.
I don't know what kind of childhood he
had,
but maybe he's just going to fight that
to the day he dies,
you know?
I don't know or maybe that I don't
understand what some people like I
don't,
I don't like some things that other
people like I don't know what's going on
in their head where they look at
something and they go,
that looks amazing,
you know,
like,
but some people that is what they like,
you know,
for him maybe it's that like people that
like to dress up like furries.
Right?
Like what?
What is,
what is it about putting on a fucking
giant mascot outfit of a squirrel that
really gets your rocks off?
I don't know.
I know,
I don't get it,
but I don't think I have to know.
You don't have to.
No,
I don't.
In terms of things like fetishes,
I don't know that someone can
understand the mindset of someone who's
into that.
You know?
I feel like that is so baked into your,
your like operating software to use that
term again.
That it's like I don't,
I don't know that that's.
If I were to explain it,
someone else would get it.
I don't think that's like that.
I think that's more like,
I like the smell of vanilla or I don't
like the smell,
right?
It turns my stomach
well.
It's weird when you find out that some
fetishes or just sort of burned into
your mind at a very young age when
you're sexually maturing.
Like Dr Chris Ryan was a friend of mine
has been on the podcast before he was
talking to me about,
um,
children,
especially boys when they're in a
certain level of puberty,
I think it's age is between 11 and 14.
Any sort of sexual encounters that they
have during those age can almost
permanently burn those,
those,
uh,
encounters into their category of sexual
attractive things.
Things that they find sexually
attractive,
including like sex with men.
And he was talking about how men can be
totally straight,
but maybe
they got blown by some guy when they
were 14,
like in some crazy,
weird moment.
And then they become attracted to men,
billowing them for like forever.
It becomes like a weird fetish.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
it's,
it's imprinted.
I forget the term he used
suggesting that therefore then they're
gay or they're not gay.
They just are introduced blowing them.
Exactly.
That's what he's suggesting.
I mean,
I'm sure there's all sorts of,
there's both,
but I think what he's saying is that
some men can be even attracted to gay
porn are attracted the idea of guys
blowing guys and not be gay,
which is,
you know,
we,
we don't like to.
We would like to make things very clean
the way we categorize things.
You'd like to have like very clean and
obvious categories.
Right.
But if we're all on a spectrum than the
categories breakdown for different
people.
Yeah.
I forget what term he used about this
imprinting,
but.
And I.
Sorry,
go ahead.
No,
that's great.
I think that younger people are much
more comfortable with the fluidity of
sexuality and with everything.
I mean,
I remember when I was in college,
there were,
there was a fair amount of girls making
out with girls,
but in front of guys like,
look at me.
I'm so wild and making out with a girl
but not,
you know.
And I feel like that's now,
you know what I'd actually don't know.
I was gonna say.
I feel like that happens all the time
now,
but I just,
I sound like a blue hair or something.
I don't actually know.
I think people
are experimenting with the idea of doing
things that are outside of the confines
of normal patterns and because they
don't like who their parents are and
they don't want to be like them,
so they want to be able to rebel.
One of the best ways to rebel is to
exhibit behaviors or indulge in
behaviors that are forbidden or they're
outside of patterns.
Right.
Who is this girl at the comedy store?
One of the waitresses was telling me
about her friend who it was.
She said it was like hilarious the way
set it because he said,
I know I'm not gay because I've had sex
with guys and I didn't like it.
And she said,
I think that's one of the most
heterosexual things that a guy could
say.
And we were laughing.
I guess so.
Right.
I'm like,
you don't really know if you like
sucking Dick and team suck a dick.
And that's what he was saying.
He's like,
I didn't know it goes.
I had sex with a guy,
I blew them,
I didn't like it at all and I'm never
doing it again,
and she was talking about his commitment
to finding out,
to not prejudging by think that people
did that in the seventies in particular,
there was a bunch of rock stars that
experimented with gay sex like Pete
towns and did it and Mick Jagger and
David Bowie supposedly did it like,
I think it was common that people were
experimenting with boundaries and they
were challenging where those boundaries
are,
where they begin and where they end.
And we also know that like homosexuality
in particular was very,
very common a long time ago.
You know,
even pet history,
you know,
that's word right.
Passed Pettis history,
isn't it?
Fucking kids.
Yeah.
Being a pet,
harassed they.
That was super common,
was it?
Yeah.
Maybe somewhere and it's.
We're so close to the.
Yes.
Yeah.
The word pedophiles does.
There's a difference between being a or
a pederastic pedophile.
One of them is like they get attracted
to it.
One of them is they engage in it.
Interesting.
But it was super common,
like really common amongst like really
respected people like socrates,
Plato.
There's a lot of people that were the,
they acknowledged that they had young
boyfriends,
like little tiny young people.
It's fucked.
But back then it wasn't fucked and
homosexuality through.
I mean the Greeks and the Romans and
they'd be constantly engaged in
homosexual behavior.
That's weird about like depictions of
them in modern media.
They don't,
they don't indulge in that like that's
like not a part of like the movie 300,
you know what I mean?
Punch dudes but fucking each other.
But if we're led to
believe
I've gone over the texts,
it seems like we're not,
we're not showing an ample amount of bud
fucking amongst students.
Interesting.
Is that it could have been so accepted
and then there could have been such a
change where up until recently,
it's like people who were truly gay did
not feel comfortable being gay.
You know,
that it could change that much.
I wonder if it's cultural.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know Jen.
It could be religion,
but it's also.
It could very well be.
What did you grow up with?
Like I think a lot of what people are is
what did you grow up with?
If you look at the variations,
you know,
you talk about the spectrum cultural
behaviors that exist in human beings.
There is a wide and varied and in some
places extremely bizarre and so you look
at like isolated tribes in particular
and you look at some of their strange
practices,
like there's this group in New Guinea
and a,
this,
they call them the semen warriors of New
Guinea and they,
one of the things they do is they take
young boys away from their mothers very
early on.
They live in these bachelor groups and
it's all just child rape.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
and they think that the only way a young
boy can grow up and develop his.
If he ingest semen,
yeah,
it's fucking crazy.
And this has been going on for thousands
of years.
Apparently this isolated tribe that does
this and these are like fierce warriors
who fucking kill their enemies and eat
them and shit.
A lot of,
a lot of cannibalism exists in some
isolated tribes,
especially around New Guinea for some
strange reason,
but what
I would think would be fascinating would
be talking to the person who escaped
that.
If assuming there are,
I mean they must.
The tribes must shed members ever
occasionally.
And then which way did they go and what
do they do?
Well,
I mean,
in a lot of ways it's a cult behavior.
Like can I have a friend who used to be
in the moonies?
I know a dude who grew up a Mooney.
I know.
Do grew up a Christian scientist or
Jehovah witness.
I know a couple.
Jehovah's Witness.
That's me too.
Former Jehovah's Witnesses.
See,
that's weird man.
That's a weird one.
And that my friends who are Jehovah's
Witnesses who are.
No,
they are no longer practicing but their
families still are o g and that creates
all sorts of problems like my friend,
um,
who,
her mom didn't come to her wedding
because I forget because what,
something about her wedding wasn't
Jehovah's Witness approved.
So she,
her mom couldn't go.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
How specific mom.
Alright.
I have a Joe Rogan question.
I have noticed,
I have noticed that you posted a lot of
images that show the brutality of
nature.
Um,
and I'm wondering what about that aspect
of nature appeals?
Well,
it's not even just the brutality of
nature,
just nature in general,
like those photos that I have over there
that,
um,
what's joke named Cj cjm photography,
cjm underscore photography sent us.
Those are these wolves in yellowstone.
I just think I just am fascinated by
wildlife,
like see those walls and they're
incredible.
They're amazing,
right?
Yeah.
There's,
um,
there's the actual photo itself.
I'm just really,
really fascinated by wildlife and for
whatever reason wild predators fascinate
me more because they're scary and just
because the way they live is so it's so
explosive and dynamic and final,
you know,
like when the image of the bear that I
posted the other day that was eating the
sheep and pulling those fields shape
that it followed from a was killed the
sheep and that was pulling the fetus out
of its body.
It's like that is just so ruthless and
brutal.
There's something about that aspect of,
um,
of nature that's just insanely,
uh,
when I,
when I say attractive,
I don't mean I love it.
Like I'm like,
yeah,
eat it up,
eat it up.
I'm excited by it.
I mean I'm,
I'm drawn to it and compelled to view it
and fascinated by the fact that these
animals exist with us on this planet
alongside us right now in the wild.
And it's one of the more amazing aspects
about North America is that North
America has these wildlife preserves,
these places like yellowstone,
these state and national parks where
they have these animals that are
wandering around and any given time you
can go to yellowstone and you could see
bison and woves and,
and bear and they don't.
I mean,
whether you're there or whether you're
not there,
that is how they live.
They live in the same way.
They've lived for millions of years and
this really barbaric raw,
natural world where it's just about
breeding and killing and trying to keep
the numbers as high as possible while,
you know,
riding it out until the Alpha male gets
too old to defend its territory.
And then gets forced out and eventually
dies and freezes to death.
I mean,
and it's this intense long running
cycle.
I'm just really,
really fascinated by wildlife in
general.
Do you think that,
because I wondered if there's an element
of it that you feel like people don't
face that that's our true nature to a
degree and like what we come from.
Cause I,
you know,
I can post nature images and it can be
like look at these puppies will get a
puppy per friending a duckling.
That's what I post.
I'm really nature though.
Well natural images.
I'm saying like,
you know,
there's,
people often don't focus on the stuff
that you're presenting.
It's like,
you know,
it's there,
but it's like,
I don't want to think about that.
It's icky and it makes me uncomfortable.
Do you,
do you delight?
Is there a part of you that wishes
people would recognize that that is a
reality more?
No,
I mean,
yes for sure.
But that's not why I'm putting it up.
I'm putting it up just because it's
compelling to me,
you know?
And I just,
when I see things that are cool,
I'm just like,
look at this fucking war,
this is wild.
Looking at that and I feel compelled to
put it up.
But I think our life,
the way we live in cities and in urban
areas is,
is insanely filtered in terms of like
our interactions with the rest of the
world,
especially when we're consuming things
that come from the outside and then it
comes not just as far as animals but
even plant life.
Even just just gardens in nature.
We're.
But we,
I think we buy too much vegetables from
the store.
We buy too many vegetables from a box
from a shelf and we stick it in a
plastic bag and we drive it away.
I think we would all to ourselves a lot
of good if we grew some.
We kind of understood this process.
Like I grow vegetables and I put them in
a salad and I chopped them up and cook
them and eat them.
And there's something incredibly
satisfying about being there for the
entire process.
Knowing that this is a seed I put in the
dirt,
I put the fertilizer up at the water and
here it is in a salad and there's a
connection to your food and to this the
life form that you're consuming itself
in that way that I don't think you get
any other way and I think I think that
the filter that we've created by
civilization,
by supermarkets,
by restaurants and things like that,
I think it's unhealthy because I think
it keeps us from a true complete
understanding of our position in this
whole thing that that bear.
The only difference between that bear in
the space that you're in right now is
just distance like that.
Bear could be right over there.
I mean it's wandering around on the
earth.
It doesn't have fences around it.
It's just distance.
That keeps it from being in Woodland
Hills walking down the street.
That's really all that stops it.
It's terrifying.
Yeah.
It's got its own environment.
It's got its own range and so it stays
in that range and eat the animals that
are in that range,
but not even just terrifying.
Just the idea that that is a life form
that coexist with us and our life form.
We have figured out a way to isolate it
in these very strange tribal systems in
these communities and civilizations and
cities.
It's very bizarre and so that's the most
appealing thing about wildlife and wild
predators,
especially predators because that's what
we're afraid of the most were afraid of
being consumed by one of these things
that just consumes their consuming
machines.
They're just walking through the woods
looking for something to consume and
that's what they do.
They try to fuck and they try to kill
things to eat them and it's so bizarre
that that's all going on right now
constantly all the time,
but most of our interactions with
animals or puppies,
dogs or cat,
hey sweetie,
here's a can of food,
open the Canada and the thing about
ground up fucking chickens and got
stuffed in.
That can.
We're weird.
We're weird and I think we're
disconnected.
One hundred percent.
Yeah,
but I.
But I'm,
I'm engrossed in it.
I'm just constantly watching nature
documentaries and paying attention to
articles about it and I'm fascinated by
it.
Are you interested in desensitizing
yourself to horrific images?
Like I've had people on my podcast
before.
It's usually people who came up in tech
who went through a phase where they felt
the need to watch beheading videos.
Unlike anything anyone would send them,
they felt the need to watch it so that
they could handle it.
This is a thought process that I can
understand.
I get why somebody,
if something really bothers them,
they would want to see it a lot and then
if that does happen,
how you see things enough,
you can get desensitized.
I think it's a really negative feeling
to watch like a reporter get his head
cut off by the Taliban or something like
that.
It's a really negative feeling that I
don't want.
I remember I watched this isis video,
one of the last ones that I watched of
these guys shooting these guys.
They had them debt face down.
The shot them all and you know,
they're just,
you see their body's reacting to the
bullets and the climb over this guy and
they cut his head off and I'm watching
them dig into this guy's neck with this
knife and pull his head up and yell Ilog
Bar and hold it up.
And,
and I remember thinking as I'm watching
that,
like,
okay,
I get it.
I it not wanting to use anymore.
I know those guys exist.
I've got it in my database.
It's there.
I don't need to be feeling like shit all
day for the rest of the day.
Thinking like,
how the fuck does everything goes so bad
that someone's making a youtube video
gunning people down and cutting their
head off with a pocket knife.
I consider this what,
what,
what?
I mean,
we,
you know,
that that guy lived to be 30 whatever
years old before he shooting this guy
and cutting this out off like what is
his experiences in his life that led him
to be at the point where he wants to
project this horrific image to the rest
of the world to put fear and terror into
the eyes of the beholder.
It's like,
what is it that he's trying to do?
Like what?
What has gone wrong?
What you're trying to say.
And again,
it's what you were saying about the
spectrum like this in the spectrum,
there's a horrific behavior is versus
beautiful behaviors.
There's this broad and I think there's
something to be said for knowing that
darkness just so that you can understand
like this is also in the mix.
This is also in the equation.
Don't look for it everywhere because
it'll fucking freak you out.
But knowing that it's there,
it's probably better.
It doesn't exist.
Yeah.
Because I think if you pretend it
doesn't exist,
that means that you pretend it doesn't
exist in yourself.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden you're getting
drunk and being an asshole.
Yeah.
A friend of mine sent me an article
about this girl who went over to,
um,
Syria to try to love her way through the
country and she was raped and killed
really quickly.
Um,
and when he,
uh,
when he sent it to me,
I remember like reading this article and
thinking like,
who?
Why would someone be so naive that they
think they could just go and hug all
these people wanted to this land?
And then she was gang raped and killed
by these Muslim guys.
And uh,
just there's a lot of people that don't
want to believe that some people had a
really shitty upbringing.
They had a shitty deal.
They were born in a terrible part of the
world.
They were exposed to horrific things
very early on in their programming is
ugly.
It's dark and ugly and filled with
trauma and pain and suffering and
violence.
And that is who they are.
But that is a reality.
That's why the people that are total 100
percent antimilitary good luck with all
that.
Good luck with it because you're,
what you're saying is you hope for the
compassion of all these people in the
world to,
that it matches up with yours.
Well,
guess what?
It doesn't because there are parts in
the world where these people are 30
years old and for 30 years they have
been exposed to horrific violence and
that is what they do.
And the,
unless they die,
this is,
this is just how they behave and you are
going to run into them and most likely
they're going to enact horrific violence
on people you know,
or on you.
There's a lot of people like that,
that,
that exists.
I used to be at a total pacifist growing
up.
So when I was young,
um,
and you know,
now I recognize that that's
unfortunately a beautiful but naive way
to go through the world because you
just,
it's just,
it's not a,
not realistic to have no military and to
think that you never need it because you
do,
you need,
you need to be able to show strength and
you need to be able to be protected and
you need to crush bullshit.
When it happens in different places,
and I hate that though,
I don't love having to have come to that
conclusion like I preferred,
I prefer.
I prefer the idea that you can just hug
people and make a difference.
That'd be beautiful and it works in
small groups.
It works in some places,
but look at North Korea,
you've got a dictatorship.
You got some evil.
Fuck who's running an entire country and
it keeps people entirely under his
thumb,
mean literally an entire country under
this guise thumb.
Yeah.
Think about what's going on right now in
the Congo.
Think about what's going on right now,
all throughout the darker aspects of the
world where people are poor and there's
violence everywhere.
There's a lot of places in the world
today that are the apocalypse there.
They're like,
there's this crazy vice piece on
Liberia.
I don't know if you ever go to vice.
Do you ever read,
come Jesus Christ have this video on
Liberia and this guy,
they call him general butt naked because
he would,
uh,
he would go into fights naked.
You going to end.
He was a part of this,
um,
civil war that was going on in Liberia,
but he was accountable.
He killed babies from these neighboring
tribes.
He would go over and kill the children
and eat their heart and they thought
that like eating a piece of a children's
heart,
a child's heart would protect you in
battle.
They would cover themselves with the
blood of these innocent children and run
through these fucking neighborhoods.
It's just horrific,
horrific stuff.
And that's going on right now.
Like Liberia right now is a terrifying,
terrifying place.
And if it happened in Los Angeles,
she would say,
Holy Shit,
the apocalypse is here.
What's the apocalypse is here on earth.
It's just not in woodland hills.
It's not in studio city.
It's not in Beverly Hills,
but it's,
it's here.
It's on earth.
Yeah,
sometimes I like that.
The awareness of how much fucked up shit
is happening all over the place is when
I am tuned into that frequency.
Like I felt very overwhelmed and just
like,
fuck,
I don't know what to do with that.
Not that I have to do anything,
but I mean I don't know what to do with
that because like on my show,
my show,
it was twice a week and on a Thursday
show I've started featuring.
I have a friend of mine who's a dog
trainer and um,
she goes to specifically the downy
shelter,
but other shelters
kill shelters and takes these dogs and
trains them and gets them more
adoptable.
And so I've been featuring a dog a week
hoping to try to get the word out.
Um,
but now that I'm aware of all these
different dogs,
I'm also aware when all of a sudden you
go to the website and it says,
you know,
someone's,
I was no longer available.
And I know what that means now.
I mean,
it means that dog has been put down as
opposed to so and so may not be
available or so and so has been adopted
or so and so's with a rescue.
It's like,
I think when it says is no longer
available.
And I used to just think,
oh,
someone adopted that dog.
It's like,
no,
that dog got put down.
And so now that I'm aware of all this,
I find I'm get emotionally attached to
each dog that I don't personally know.
And it's,
I'm overwhelmed with the sadness of
that.
And then I think like this is,
this is nothing compared to the
horrendous awfulness on every level.
It's hard to that thing of like,
I want to make the tiniest difference in
one little life.
It's easy for me to just feel
overwhelmed,
to try to even be doing anything because
there's always something so much,
much
worse.
Yeah,
that's a good way of describing it.
There is always something somewhere,
something so much worse.
But I think in some weird way that also
makes us appreciate when things are
good.
And that's one of the more unique
aspects of today is that you can pay
attention to some of the horrific parts
of the world and go,
wow,
we are so fucking lucky that we're not
trapped in North Korea.
We're so lucky that we're not living in
the Congo.
We're so lucky that.
I mean,
my friend Justin,
he,
uh,
builds wells in the Congo and he goes to
the Congo and he's there for like six
months at a time,
just got malaria for the second time and
he's,
I mean he's a,
just a gem of a human being and he is a
part of this,
this charity called fight for the
forgotten where he goes and it helps
these pygmies build water wells and
maintains them for them and stuff like
that.
But this guy's experience when he talks
about the horrific plight of these
people and we'll all the gun through,
gone through and all the persecution
they've,
they've experienced it just really you
leave and you want to be nicer to
people.
You want to listen to him talk and you
listen to his experiences.
You,
you one have hope because the guy's
willing to leave Dallas,
Texas and fly down to the Congo and,
and become a part of these people's
lives and try to help them and elevate
them.
So there's all this hope for humanity in
that this person that has no real
connection with these folks other than
just meeting them once and then falling
in love with their tribe,
that that is possible.
But it's also,
it makes you realize like,
God,
we were looking for problems today.
We're looking for things to be
automated.
Should I fixed my nose?
Do you know what I mean?
But things could be so much worse.
And again,
it comes back to that spectrum and the
spectrum of information that we're,
that we can access today.
It's almost mean there's,
the brain is really not a,
it's not really available to tune into
all these different parts,
the world all the time.
And so you could,
it's so easy to lose focus.
It's so easy to lose
effective.
It really is.
I just,
um,
I went to France a couple of weeks ago.
We could go because you go to Paris.
I did three scared.
No.
Um,
we originally were going to go in
December and we rescheduled even though
I know that the chances of anything
actually happening are so small and it's
almost that thing of like,
I'm not that special that it's,
something's going to happen to me,
you know,
but I think there is that after the
attack we started thinking maybe this
is,
you know,
why were we going in the winter anyway?
Everyone says it's not the best time to
go,
so let's just postpone it because we had
always been debating should we go in
December,
April.
Um,
but then after I,
I wasn't scared once we made the
decision to go,
but I wondered are we making the wrong
decision?
But once I was there I was absolutely.
I also moved to New York.
I'm like shortly after nine slash 11.
And once I was there I was not scared.
It's,
I think,
feel like for me,
the fear is more in contemplating going
there.
Um,
but anyway,
being there,
being in another country where my daily
thoughts aren't like,
Oh,
I've got to check twitter all the time
and I've got to do this.
Like whatever.
The bullshit of my daily life is having
that instead be replaced with,
I'm just trying to remember how to say
this word and try and like trying to
communicate with people and hoping they
can understand me.
Um,
and looking into all this beautiful art
and you know,
everything that you do.
Um,
it really upon coming back,
I'm finding readjusting into the date.
My daily routine is more difficult and I
don't want to.
I don't want to go back to a caring so
much about minute bullshit.
I feel like that's kind of the gift of
travel.
Not local travel,
not small trips,
but the gift of going to another country
or being around people who speak a
different language,
um,
is that it kind of like takes your brain
and treat it like a snow globe and then
everything kind of gets readjusted and
you remember that there's a so much more
than whatever it is you've been waking
up and thinking about
also that their world is so vastly
different.
The language is different.
The sounds they make are different.
Their traditions are different,
their customs are different,
the food they eat is different.
The neighborhoods,
they walked down and live in our
different there.
There are established patterns are just
different.
And then when you experience those
different patterns and different
cultures and different cities,
I think it's,
it's,
it makes you just go,
oh yeah,
it's a big fucking world.
You know,
might it,
cause it's so easy to think that it's
all exactly as that your life is very
similar to whatever the life that
everyone else is living in the world.
Go out there.
Like I kept,
I was thinking,
and by the way,
I'm not,
it's not like I was in the rain forest
or something.
Like I recognized I was in a place that
all things considered is actually pretty
similar to where we.
But um,
we went out to [inaudible] one day and
sort of drove to the countryside and
that's where Monet Monet lived and what
he painted,
um,
it's,
it's his house and there's the gardens
that he painted.
Oh Wow.
You can go visit his house.
It's really cool.
But I was thinking,
what if you just lived out here?
Like what is,
what is that life like to your,
you're,
you know,
an hour,
you're in the countryside,
like what do they do?
What goes on?
Because of course,
because I,
to me it's like,
it feels like very little goes on,
but that's probably not.
Well I think it's similar to the drive
up to San Francisco,
drive up to San Francisco.
You take the five and you stop at one of
those like farm towns.
You like what in the fuck you know,
and I want to go to a restaurant and
talk to some kid is like washing dishes
and go,
hey man,
grow up here.
What the fuck did you do?
What do you guys do?
How much math do you guys have?
Like what's going on?
That's where people get like super
desperado and drugs too because they're
just looking for some kind of crazy
escape.
You'll just drive into town of 3000
people in the middle of nowhere and
you're like,
what?
What is the.
And there's a lot of right wing shit up
there too.
That was one of the weirdest things.
I've always think.
I always think of California as being
pretty left wing,
pretty open minded,
pretty liberal.
I grew up in Orange County,
so I did not have that sense of awe
when you drive up like through the farm
areas,
like you'll see like these gigantic Mitt
Romney for president sides.
This was like during the election,
but uh,
I remember driving up there going like
in the,
you know,
Obama is the,
is the real enemy of our country,
like these big ass billboards where
people had put up not,
not just like a thought that they had,
but they wanted to project it out to
everybody driving up there buying apples
or whatever the fuck they're buying
apples or math or math.
We were part of Orange County from
a corona del Mar.
Super right wing,
right?
Very.
Yeah.
It waS very homogenous.
Very,
very white,
very blond,
blue eyed,
great athletic killer.
Yes.
It really is.
That's the,
that's their cash crop.
Journalistic is very athletic and we'll
just that foR the kids that I went to
school with were just very good at
sports and they valued that.
Uh,
and,
you know,
I,
I definitely do not feel like I fit in.
I was,
it was,
it was round and soft and pasty and had
black hair and brown eyes and just could
not keep up.
Uh,
I always joked that it was like a leni
riefenstahl wet dream there.
Um,
it was just very this very that,
that the pride of white people there.
Um,
and I resented growing up there and then
once I got older I realized all the,
the,
you know,
I realize why my parents moved there
because I was born in oakland and
apparently it was kind of rough.
So they,
uh,
they fled with the rest of the white
people to orange county where it's
incredibly safe and everything is
manicured and the schools are nice and
you know,
it's safe being the prominent thing I
think.
And growing up I was like,
why,
why the fuck would you choose this place
where we're so different in every way?
Then eVeryone here,
I didn't get it.
And then,
You know,
as an older,
as an adult,
I go back and I,
and I see it is,
it's nice and it is peaceful and it is
calm and I get why you'd want to raise
your kids there.
It was weird that you get these groups
of white people together and they just
calm the fuck down.
I'm just looking to sit with a bunch of
other white people and calm down.
I'm doing the irvine improv this
weekend,
like the safest city in America and like
fucking 100 years running or something
crazy.
I grew up in a bar in town and I thought
irvine was more boring,
more boring,
but it's a great place to do stand up.
Nice folks.
Yeah.
How did you get.
What was your path to get on?
Like the adam carolla show?
What was your path to get into
podcasting?
A.
Okay.
So I started writing for magazines and
newspapers.
Very young.
And how old were you?
I was 18 and I did some stuff for the la
times.
That's awesome.
Thank you.
Must be a fucking bang up writer.
I,
I'm,
I'm okay with words.
And stuff,
I was good,
I was very in love with myself.
I was like la times today,
you know,
my stars just I,
I really thought as a freelancer because
then I went to college,
freelanced all through college,
came back to orange county,
began writing for people and for rolling
stone and it happened fast and I was
young and I was like,
there's just no stopping me.
And I didn't realize that,
like,
no,
it kinda just,
it,
it's not like I do this today and then
cover of vanity fair tomorrow.
Like first of all there's only so far
I'm going to be able to get if I'm
staying in orange county.
And I ended up,
like I said,
playing in a band.
I'm writing for the osi weekly while
still doing the band.
I played guitar.
Did you really?
I played drums too.
I was the drummer initially.
Uh,
and there were three of us and I was
like,
you know,
don't get too in love with me because
I'm not staying in orange county for the
ice.
Moved back to orange county and I was
there for five years after college and
the entire time I was like,
this is not where I'm supposed to be,
this is not what I wanted to do with my
life.
I was,
I'm sure it was such an unpleasant
asshole to be around because I was like,
no,
I've changed.
But back then,
yeah,
it was like a year for the band.
like don't get too used to.
I'm not,
I'm not staying here.
Experiences limb.
Yeah.
And especially I feel bad because a
couple of the people in the band,
um,
I mean they're still in bands,
like they really wanted to make this
happen and I was like,
this is just my stupid little thing I'm
doing on the side while I'm pursuing
what I'm really trying to pursue in
college.
I love the college I went to.
I'm glad I went to college,
I believe in college,
but I also think it can make you a
little bit insufferable and that's who I
was when I graduated.
So I was writing at a certain point,
I was like,
I have to have like my,
the life that I want to lead is headed
this way,
but the one I'm leading is going this
way and I've got to bridge the gap.
So I moved To New York,
I made the decision to move to New York
and then nine slash 11 happened like six
days after I made the decision and I was
like,
I don't care.
I'm going anyway even though I know.
I'm glad I did though.
What was the thought process behind New
York?
I,
um,
so the most cosmopolitan,
most writing because that was my,
you know,
writing for magazines was my thing and
writing in general,
it was kind of the way it was where all
that took place.
Like all the people that I was talking
to when I was freelancing for national
magazines,
we're based in New York.
It just seemed like the place to go for
that.
it also,
I wanted to be in a city and I remember
my band toured and I met this guy and I
was walking around san francisco and san
francisco felt like such a city to me
and I was like,
I really want to be in a place that has
the feel of a city.
And I met this guy who worked at the
venue that we were playing and he was
telling me that he was moving to
brooklyn because san francisco Just
wasn't enough of a city for him.
And I remember the kind of that was
blowing my mind.
so I was like,
this feels like such a city to me if
this isn't the city enough,
like what am I doing in these cow
pastures in orange county?
So,
um,
I made the decision to move and then
eventually moved and I was there for
about nine years.
First couple of years,
much,
much more difficult than I thought it
was.
I,
I felt weirdly insecure and I hadn't
expected to feel socially insecure,
but I just,
I left everything.
I knew.
I left the bay.
Like I didn't know where I fit in.
Suddenly,
um,
especially after having been in the band
like that my whole life during the time
I was in the band was,
and also I wrote about music before I
was ever in the band,
so my life was going to shows or playing
shows and I had a group of friends and a
community that I really missed once I
left them.
So then I was in New York and I was
like,
I don't have friends and I don't have a
job and I'm freelancing,
but it's not enough.
I don't know what I'm doing and I feel
very alone and I feel uncomfortable and
weird.
Thankfully that went away.
It just took longer than I thought it
would.
Um,
got a job at time out New York where I
worked for a number of years and while I
was at time out New York,
um,
they were looking for editors to go on
television to talk about events goIng on
in the city.
So I said,
I,
I'm like,
I'll do it.
And um,
and it was channel four.
So wbc,
they really liked me and they wanted me
to keep coming back and doing it every
saturday morning.
Um,
so when they initially they were going
to have a group of editors doing it and
they decided they just wanted,
which I thought was,
was great because I was so destined for
greatness and it gets all happening.
That's how I felt.
Um,
I hope it's clear that I'm trying to be
self deprecating worry.
I'm coming off as an asshole
anyway.
Um,
I began doing that a lot and I realized
I really enjoyed that.
I enjoyed the,
that performance element.
I guess I'm right.
I like to go on,
on camera.
Um,
started doing other tv stuff.
and then I was aware of youtube and I
was experimenting with youtube and I was
putting my,
my television clips.
I started doing a lot of new stuff.
I was putting my television clips on
youtube and then I don't know what made
me decide one day,
like,
what if I just recorded myself doing
some book reviews.
I would,
if I just did,
just talked,
you know,
the question to answer,
like talk directly to my little bit of
an audience that I'm beginning to have
because have a blog as well.
Um,
and so I did that and the response to
that was so overwhelming.
I was like,
oh,
people don't care if it's polished when
you're dealing with the internet.
It's more about the immediacy and it's
more about you talking to them.
So I started getting into that and
started doing the various web shows.
Um,
and then I created a show called alison
rosen engineer,
best friend on ustream and I would do
that.
It was a talk show from my living room
that I woUld do for three hours every
sunday evening.
And it was not that dissimilar.
There's so many negatives in that
sentence from the podcasts that I have
now.
That's where I started.
A lot of the segments that I do now was
on that show.
And by the way,
I remember when I was used streaming you
were also on ustream and oftentimes on
the front page of ustream it would,
it would have me and you way back when?
Cruising.
Ma'am.
Are you still on ustream?
Yeah,
we don't stream on ustream anymore
because we were doing it and we're
trying to do it simultaneously with
youtube.
But there's something wrong with our tri
caster.
I see.
Still sucks when it doesn't really want
to do it,
It would work.
It's just not solid and in one will drop
off and crash.
So we had to choose one platform.
And the thing about youtube is youtube
lets you pause and it lets you backtrack
while you're actually watching it.
Ustream doesn't support that future and
there's more users or watching youtube.
So we just decided to jump ship.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I had begun to wonder
is the audience there for online
streaming visual stuff in the same way
that they're there for podcasts?
I remember listening,
I was friends with doug benson and
listening to his podcast and I got this
curiosity about podcasts and then I
heard that adam corolla was looking for
a news girl and I was still in New York
at the time,
um,
and I like tried to send them my stuff
and I didn't hear anything and I'm like,
okay,
well I did,
I did what I can and no one's getting
back to me.
Um,
and then very rapIdly someone in my
family got sick and I moved from New
York to California to be with them
because we didn't.
That turns that that person Is actually
doing very well now.
But at the time it wasn't clear what
direction it was going to go.
And so I,
it didn't make sense to stay in New
York,
um,
when this was happening.
So I moved back kind of suddenly.
And then around the time that I was
lying on my parent's couch being like,
what the hell did I do?
Why did I,
I don't think that I made the right
move.
And coming back,
I got an email from like august and I
think the entire message was in the
subject line and it was just like,
you know,
adam carolla show this day,
this time,
can you come in?
And I said sure.
So I did.
And I auditioned and then they narrowed
it down to like four of us and then I
auditioned again and then I got the job.
So yeah,
it was,
it was nice.
Do you like doing your own thing better?
Um,
I began doing my own thing while I was
still there and I really enjoy doing my
own thing.
Yeah.
I also really liked being on that show
too,
you know,
I'm grateful for the four years that I
had there and I,
there's a lot of positive memories,
also a fair amount of things that I
think that was fucked up.
But you just sort of what I just did.
You don't have to.
I don't want you to.
I feel like you do want me to.
I don't want to do.
We don't want to do,
you know,
whenever I talk about it,
it's funny,
I was thinking on this other day
whenever I talk about.
No,
I was thinking about this today close
thinking about this show and if it were,
if it was going to come up or not.
Um,
whenever I talk about all the stuff that
happened on that show near the end when
I was no longer on the show,
um,
I simultaneously afterwards wish I had
said nothing and wish I had said more.
It's so weird.
And I was like,
why?
Why do I have those dual competing
feelings?
And I think the reason is because I have
mixed feelings about the whole thing.
Like there's part of me that so thankful
for my time on the show and thankful
that I was given that opportunity and
you know,
we toured and I learned so much and I
have the best time and all that and
there's part of me that's like,
hey,
fuck you for not respecting me enough as
a human being to have a conversation
with me.
I sat next to you for four years.
Like you mean about the way you test?
Yeah.
So it makes sense.
Um,
I think that I still have mixed feelings
about everything,
but you know,
I'm aware of how fortunate I was and I'm
grateful for so much and I'm also,
I also feel like there were certain
elements of it that I think we're,
we're fucked up like I said.
So,
um,
where was I going with all of that
though?
You were talking about the bad aspects
of it.
Oh yeah.
Well no,
you were saying too.
I like doing my own thing.
Um,
yes I do,
but I.
But there's elements I miss.
Well,
you were good on the show.
I remember that's where we met,
you know,
the times that you thought you and I had
some interesting exchanges or on the
show were you,
you were really tuned in like I,
I feel like I really love adam,
but I feel like adam is like,
you go over a guy's house and there's
just a bunch of locked doors and you can
hang out with them in the living room
when it's time to leave you leave and
you never get to see what's in those
locks
doors.
You don't.
Yeah.
You don't always feel like or ever feel
like you connect.
Yeah,
but that's just him.
That's his personality.
He's just a guy who isn't this like he's
got that radio persona or the tv
persona,
whatever the fuck it is.
And it's like this is,
this is his range,
this is where he's going down.
YoU know?
And so when you and I would have
conversations on the show,
one of the thIngs that I liked,
like you would ask like these
provocative questions,
you probe and do things and I don't
think necessarily he does know it was,
it was an interesting mixture.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I,
I thought so too.
So it was a surprise to me to find out
that he was unhappy.
He does argue or anything?
No.
Do you mean on air or.
We either one
never off air,
never off air.
Everything was always really cordial and
I thought,
I honestly thought everything was fine.
I thought everything was good.
I thought we were in a good place.
Like I was very,
very surprised to find out that how
wrong I was about how he was feeling
about everything.
Um,
and I only found that out because I was
fired,
you know,
and then he did an episode where he
talked about everything and it was like
I was kind of blown away by all the f
and I didn't listen to it for awhile,
but people were tweeting me,
a lot of people were tweeting me these
things like why'd you do this?
Why'd you do this?
And I'm like,
I didn't do any of that.
Like that is all,
it's not true.
And it was when,
when you're saying that you have to
explain what you're talking about.
Okay.
I'm trying to think of like one of the,
one of the shining example.
Well,
is this going to be one of those
simultaneous
too much and it makes me the most
uncomfortable is getting into the weeds
with all the details because yeah,
just sounds so petty.
It's like,
don't talk about it.
Bring it up.
It's no big deal.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's weird though.
I don't know why I'm so afraid to get to
talk about it either.
You know that there's going to be a
bunch of people that have opinions and
it's all gonna come down on both sides.
It's going to be supportive people and
there's going to be negative.
Right?
Then they're going to try to tweet it.
Adam,
this flow can be sustainable.
You gave her an opportunity and she's
not getting.
Well.
Yes,
exactly.
Like I'm not gratefuL and she's not
getting oveR it either.
You know,
they feel like they're going to say
that.
how long ago was it that you left?
It was,
um,
very tail end of 2014.
Yeah,
get over it.
It's two years.
Well,
that's the funny thing is that I am
totally over it,
but it does come up.
Things
like podcasts,
I mean,
obviously it's got a giant show.
No,
it's going to come up.
Honestly.
It
was a good thing for me to go off on my
own.
Were yoU starting to go off on your own
while you were doing his show?
You doing another show from his studio
thing because he's got like a bunch of
different little.
I was doing my show on his network and
then he just stopped and he stopped and
started doing our own.
Well I got,
I got kicked off of.
I got,
I got the boot and we kicked off the
network to.
Yeah,
well I was surprised by that as well.
It was just a whole like,
we're done with you.
Wow.
So I began doing my show on my own.
And did it make you reexamine how you do
your show?
Oh uh,
what?
In what way did you try to like,
was there a.
Was there a part of you that was like,
okay,
well is there something about me that's
annoying?
Is there something about me that's
grading,
like what is a,
you know what I'm saying?
Like why did this happen?
Well,
you know what I said to you early in the
podcast where you can tell I go,
oh,
there's a podcast or is mine because
you're like worrying some people gonna
look at this.
They're going to approach it a certain
way.
Like you're constantly examining.
If you're trying to do a podcast,
you're trying constantly examining,
okay,
am I talking too much?
Is as boring as this repetitive,
like how do I juice this up?
How to make this exciting.
When you recovered from that and you're
like,
okay,
now I'm on my own.
Like,
does it make you tentative date?
Did you say,
okay,
I have to maybe be less bold or maybe
more cautious or maybe more aware.
I think that
all the extra attention that was on me
after it happened
made me
speak in the way that I'm speaking right
now,
which is super unnatural and really
halting and examining every word before
I say it.
You know,
it did,
it did.
Um,
because okay,
now I'm just going to talk about some of
it immediately afterwards when they were
all these people coming to people
tweeting at me like,
why didn't you do this?
Why didn't you do this?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
I wanted to set the record straight.
Um,
and someone that I,
a mentor that someone that I look up to
but who doesn't come from podcast and
you comes from old media was like,
don't take the bait allison,
don't do it.
Like when the dust settles,
do not get in there.
Just allow,
just be,
you know,
take the high road because everyone can
see what's happening today.
And it may like that night I had planned
to be like,
here's my side of the story,
here's my response to this,
to this,
to this.
Like I was going to get into it because
it,
there was so much untruth out there and
I had very simple like,
no this,
you know,
let me read,
here's the email,
here's what this said,
here's this.
This is not the way it went down.
You guys are getting,
are getting a distorted version of
things.
But then I listened to this guy and I
was like,
that makes a lot of sense,
so I am just going to say thank you for
the great time that I had on the show
and I wish you the best and I did that.
And then for the next two months I
chafed against that because it's like I
agree that that is a great position to
take,
but if you have an audience,
if you have a podcast,
that podcast,
depending on the kind of products you
have,
but for the most part it's predicated on
the relationship you have with the
listeners and the fact that you are
honest with them and you're transparent
and you're,
you're your authentic,
genuine self.
So all of a sUdden I did not know how to
be my authentic genuine self while also
trying to be like very to,
to not discuss this thing.
That was such a big thing obviously.
And so I was kind of like going
vacillate and going back and forth and,
and being authentic in every way other
than this one topic that I wasn't
talking about it.
And then it surprised,
like,
why am I not talking about it?
It feels so weird to not be talking
about it.
So then I finally did talk about it and
it was a couple months later,
um,
but even,
but,
and,
and that specifically is a thing where
I'm like,
I wish I had never said any of that
were talking though.
But you're,
you're talking,
arriving,
talking around it.
But even in doing so,
you're still discussing it.
Yeah.
You know,
you're spending an inordinate amount of
time like thinking about it and
discussing it.
Right?
So just mean you and I had discussed it
to,
you know,
my thoughts were pretty much the same,
just don't,
don't bother,
just kick ass,
go do your shit,
don't worry about it.
You know,
and people,
there's gonna be times where people just
don't.
That doesn't work.
It doesn't gel.
Maybe it jelled for you more than a job
for him.
Or maybe the opportunity was better for
you than it was for him.
You know,
it's,
um,
people shouldn't be forced to have to
work together,
especIally in show business.
I hundred percent agree with,
by the way,
in no way was I ever like this is he
shouldn't have made this decision.
Seems to marry,
you know,
was network though.
That doesn't make any sense.
That seems lIke there was something more
to it because if you guys stopped
working together and he just kept you on
his network and helped promote you and,
and pumped you up.
That seems.
That seems more amicable.
Like it makes sense.
It seems like.
So
what I'm saying,
that's what I'm saying about how it
didn't make sense to me is like,
there he is pissed and I don't know why
we're going to do.
Yeah.
Do your own show.
That's what I think.
I'll start doing that.
You've already been doing this.
How's it going?
It's going really well.
Do you want it twice a week.
Twice a week.
Monday a one-on-one and thursday is,
there's a panel of us and it's going
really well and I really like it.
And um,
yeah,
everything's good to go.
Just don't worry about it.
I'm not worrying about it.
But you are because you talked about it
right.
When I talk about it,
I worry about the fact that I just
talked about it and I can't.
I can't get to the bottom of why that
is.
I mean,
like I said before,
I think it's because I'm up different
minds about it,
but it might just be because there's so
much immediate online response.
Anytime I dance around it,
that's one of the more difficult things
about anything that you're putting out
there,
whether it's a talk show or a podcast or
fucking even an album or anything.
It's the navigating the response and the
social media response is just so
different than the response that you
would have gotten a few decades ago or a
decade ago.
It's just,
it's so different.
It's a different world and no one knows
exactly how to handle it.
Right.
I mean they can give you really good
advice,
but no one's done it.
No one said,
well,
in the 30 years of my career when
twitter came along,
you know,
they don't really have that to say so
you can eat in the paralysis by analysis
that you were.
Yeah.
We were just talking about fighting
term.
You know,
like you analyze things too much when
you're fighting and you freeze up,
you don't know what to do.
He hesitates is lost you.
So when you,
you're unfortunately incapable of being
yourself because you worried about
criticism.
That's also something that clients want.
They want,
they want to be able to fuck with you to
the point where I see her,
you know,
allIson reads my tweets,
I see words,
but what she says no because me and then
they like,
yeah,
good,
good job on rogan's podcast.
You fucking dumb bitch.
Talk about yourself much.
Oh,
and then you think about that the next
time you talk and then they creep into
your head and
that's why I tried to not expose the to
the degree that I can.
I try not to expose myself to it because
I,
I think to myself,
this is not helping me to do any,
to be good at anything.
This is not making a better show when I
do my own show.
This is making me concerned that these
18 ads are upset with something.
You know?
It can give you a different perspective.
Occasionally someone can say something
that will eliminate some aspects of your
own behavior that maybe you weren't
aware of that as possible,
but it's also possible that you can tap
into a river of cons and just drown
and you can also use you because I've
swum in those rivers swam spanner.
Did you see that video that I posted the
other day about one of the most
dangerous rivers in the world and it's
insanely deceptive.
I tweeted it yesterday.
I believe this is crazy.
There's this place in england and it's
this river that if you look at it,
it looks like a calm,
just sort of meandering river just
doesn't like anything exceptional,
but the way it's cut into the,
to the ground,
what you're seeing is not the entire
river.
There's an underlying aspect of it with
torrential currents.
So if you get stuck in it,
if you go in it,
you literally can't escape.
Did you get smashed up against the rocks
and you get killed?
Like,
here,
play this.
It looks so plastic.
Let this play,
uh,
jimmy,
it is the most dangerous stretch of
water anywhere on earth.
How crazy is that?
It's a bold claim.
What's the name of this video?
Lives and never rapids and the most
dangerous stretch of water in the world.
This is treated.
Is that what it says?
Straight up street in bolton.
Some woods.
You could jump over.
People occasionally do,
but if you miss that jump,
it'll kill you.
This is what the rIver looks like about
100 meters upstream,
same river.
All that water went down thanks to the
local geology.
The river basically turns on its side,
help passages and tunnels in the rocks
below.
Those banks are actually overhangs.
There isn't any riverbed just belOw the
surface.
It's a deep boiling mass of fast and
deadly currents.
There were claims that falling in has a
100 percent fatality rate.
Uh,
there's no way to confirm that,
of course,
because a local person doesn't die and
river doesn't make the news.
But,
uh,
it has claimed a lot of lives there.
Even tales from the twelfth century of
young boy said to be the future king of
scotland who died trying to jump across
those waters on anything or anyone that
falls in might not come out in any
recognizable form.
It could just get polarized against the
rocks and the water over and over and
over again.
That's fine.
put a cameron,
but then I'd have to get close to the
edge and the edge isn't sharp.
It just cubs towards the water and it's
covered in slippery moss.
Besides the mortar is opaque and brown
with pit stain,
you'd see nothing it survivable.
It's one of those things where you
really have to look at it,
so people listening to this go and check
out the video.
What is it?
Is it on vimeo?
What is it on your tongue?
Youtube.
The videos.
Much better representation because what
they do is they show you what the river
looks like at its widest part,
which is enormous,
and then it cuts down into a small area
that you can jump across and it's so
much water rolling through such a small
area that it creates this intense
current and just fucking bizarre,
right?
It's like an optical illusion because it
just feels like a stream that looks like
enough.
Meanwhile it'S super deep and raging
beneath it and you just can't.
The subconscious
deep river of cons,
but you know,
and that's like in a lot of ways it's
what you're dealing with and now we got
to that,
but that's where it was.
Right?
River of cons.
That's what we were talking about.
Even for them,
you know,
the people that are doing that,
a lot of times they don't even realize
the harm they're doing to themselves in
their own psyche by just lashing out of
people.
I went to,
this guy's a page yesterday.
he was tweeting at someone I know really
negative shit and I went to his page and
his entire twitter page,
which is him shitting on various famous
people and trying to get them to respond
to him like what a bizarre life and also
the water.
It's got to be incredibly damaging to
your self esteem,
to be just constantly lashing out at
famous people and trying to get them tO
respond to you.
Just trying to insult them,
trying to troll them.
So bizarre always makes me wonder,
is it young people?
Is it like people who are in that phase
of life where you're young and you're
angry?
Some of them you just need an outlet.
Some of them,
yeah,
some of them were older men.
Some of it's men.
You know,
like if you ever ran into a man who's in
his fifties,
never had a family,
never been married.
There's a weirdness to those folks.
There's a real weirdness to these older
set in their ways.
Guys that never really settled down with
anybody.
You will run into him oCcasionally and
you're like,
whoa,
there's like you,
you,
you're surviving without a heart.
Like you're,
you know what I mean,
like when one of these people that's
your missing organs or something like
that,
you're missing a critical aspect of what
it means to be a person.
Right.
I noticed,
um,
a fair amount of,
of hate that I was getting.
This is years ago,
I had noticed a pattern that I would
oftentimes discover,
like I would,
I would get some shitty comment and then
I would go to the person's page and they
had a newborn and it was like a lot of
brand new dads and that really surprised
me that like it's brand new dads who are
writing shitty things.
Yeah.
Um,
and my husband's theory is like,
yeah,
because they're not getting sex so.
Well,
that's a weird theory.
They're tired,
I would say.
I mean,
I think his theory,
yes,
they're tired and there's been this huge
change in their relationship
or they're just assholes and the baby
didn't cure it.
The thing that was most overwhelming to
me,
I'm having a baby was like how
compassion I felt for other people.
How I felt like,
oh,
these other people that are all fucked
up,
or just babies,
they were babies that were just exposed
to the wrong stimuli,
the wrong life,
the wrong emotions,
the wrong family,
the wrong schools.
And then here you are a raging twat at
30,
you know,
that's a lot of human beings.
I mean,
we're essentially long running
equations.
All of our life experiences and
interactions calculated to alison rosen.
Two thousand 16.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
It's why it's why it's interesting when
you sit here and you tell me about your
life experience,
you know,
born in,
oakland moving to orange county.
I gotta get outta here.
I'm in a band,
but I'm going to leave.
I'm in New York and you know,
and then did,
did,
did all these different interactions and
different engagements.
And then boom,
now you're here and you are the sum
total of these experiences and your
reflections on these experiences.
And it's one of the reasons why people
that have lived fucked up lives are the
most interesting.
and people that have these mundane self
absorbed existences are the most boring
because they really haven't had the
trials and tribulations.
I really haven't had those moments where
they had to question themselves and try
to figure out what the fuck they're
doing with themselves that when you do
that and you hit those low points and
then rebound,
that's where life's lessons happen.
I agree.
And it's kind of weird as a parent
because I don't want my kids to face
adversity.
You know,
I want my kids have a really fun time.
But I also know that unless they do,
unless they do face disappointment and
some adversity,
at least some,
they're not going to get a full,
full handle on how to manage those
waters.
You know,
do fall into the river of cons.
Don't know what to do.
So like I swim in the river of freely
been around them for so long.
Now it's know you're not gonna fuck with
my zen that easy.
But if I lived an entire entirely
sheltered life,
how much of how much my resilience would
I have,
you know?
And how much resilience do people have
where they don't experience life outside
of their very small existence.
They're very small community.
they're very small pattern of life
experiences.
Right?
That Is that sort of letting my kids go
through adversity.
ThAt part I know is going to be hard for
me because I'm the kind of person where
like if there's someone in the corner
that has an itch,
I'm like,
let me come over and scratch it for you
though.
I don't want you to feel discomfort.
Like I'm very tuned into.
I mean,
are you going to be a helicopter parent?
Got to hope not.
I don't.
Just women when they,
when they have children later in life,
that's when they're most likely to
helicopter.
There's a lot of helicopter parents at
my kid's school.
I probably will be.
I want to be the right level of
helicopter parent to like keep my kids
safe and I'm happy but not fuck them up
wIth being smothering.
Right.
Tod,
it's going to be.
The challenge for me I think is tough
action.
It's,
it's interesting.
Everybody does it different and kids
come out different.
Then there's also like my two kids are
so fucking dissembler there,
so dissembler there's age difference.
One of them is almost seven or one of
them is actually just turned eight
rather,
and one of them is almost six,
so out of the box,
the six year old is the one who eats
candy and becomes a barbarian.
She's so much depth.
She'll.
She's six soon,
but she's so much different than her
sister is.
They're just so different and they grew
up in the same loving,
same amount of attention,
same amount of resources,
you know,
obviously slightly different life
experiences can be no different.
Of course,
different friends,
different things,
but it's not just that it's the innate
personality,
like they come out of the box different.
well,
that's something I wonder.
I mean,
when you're saying that sitting here,
I'm the sum total of everything I've
experienced.
Yes,
but I also think how much is just
genetic counseling there too.
yeah.
It's also the variabilities,
like there's,
it's not just genetics that are
variable.
It's like those genetics very,
you know,
like brothers and sisters are different
in some parents.
I'm wondering what the combination is
like how much of your husband is going
to be in your kid and how much of it's
you and is it a 50 slash 50 split,
right?
Or do your and how much of that other
guy?
Yeah.
And do your jeans just dominate is like,
you know,
ever seen like a person who's blond
haired and blue eyed and if the kid
doesn't look anything like them,
like oh,
you just get your genes got dominated by
the other genes.
Right.
I don't know.
It's,
it's interesting.
My sister who has the same coloring as I
do,
has a blonde blue eyed baby was so
weird.
Her husband,
his is blonde and blue eyed,
but it's like I just,
I just believed that the dark jeans
would dominate and they did not fighting
jeans to go over.
I guess.
So yeah,
it can happen.
It's interesting
also,
not just that,
like the genetic variables which which
are are,
are truly fascinating personality
variables,
all these different things,
but also how they interact with each
other,
which is going to be so much different
than how you interact with them and
watching kids interact with each other
and getting annoyed at each other and
trying to work that out and what
watching their own little personality
disputes that they have and how they
navigate those and little tools they
have.
Like my,
my youngest one cries at everything.
Everything's like to like,
like go way overboard and settle down,
relax,
you know,
because they figure out like if I cry I
get hugs and someone picks me up and so
that's the move.
So anything that goes wrong,
I'm just gonna start crying.
So like I'll,
I'll watch her,
like she'll do something wrong,
her sister will get pissed at you at her
and then she'll run away crying that her
sister did something like,
whoa,
hold on.
I just watched it.
I watched that whole thing go down.
That's not how it went.
And then the cries.
Okay.
Bigger and so it becomes like you don't
want your kid to be a cry baby.
You also want your kid to recognize that
you know exactly when or what went on,
but you also want to let them know that
it's okay.
So that's where I've always gone to the.
I did the exact same thing when I was
your age and I think that's a big one.
Like letting them know and then,
you know,
not letting it go to no,
no harp on it.
Sled it,
go,
all right,
come on,
give me a hug,
let's go play with some stuff like let
it go because they,
they learn themselves,
they see themselves that things don't
work.
They see themselves,
they got called out on their
manipulation.
Like,
oh,
I got my fucking ran my crying game and
I shut down today,
but no one's getting mad,
you know?
So it's not like I'm a terrible person.
I need to feel awful,
but crying gained don't work on daddy.
I like that.
The idea that the stakes aren't that
high.
I think I grew up with the feeling at
all times and that the stakes were very
high and I,
you know,
I have parents who have that the stakes
are high attitude towards everything
where it's like,
this is this,
this,
the stakes are very low here,
but they're just very,
you know,
prone to anxiety and prone to a
overreacting
people.
So it's also those stakes are entirely
dependent upon like what are,
what's,
what's the full extent of the
possibilities of things can go right or
wrong,
right?
Like,
whaT's the worst that could happen?
And if it's not a big deal then.
So it happens.
Just you'll fix it.
Right?
But it's a perspective issue.
If you're living in the Congo,
whatever issue came up wouldn't come up
at all.
Like I guarantee you these people that
are like trying to find water,
don't look at their nose and go,
god,
I've got to figure out a way to get out
of the Congo and get to beverly hills.
Get my fucking nose fixed.
My nose.
Not talking about your nose,
my nose.
Nope.
I'm talking about Congo person's nose.
You're just making it.
You're tAlking about my nose and I get
what you're saying.
You're telling me that you think I
should get plastic surgery I think gets
you this.
That's what I'm getting from them.
I felt like
the entire time I was on joe rogan's
podcast,
he was judging my nose and I don't want
to talk about it but I don't want to
talk about it.
So it's like one of those things
I feel like I could say too much or sued
simultaneously on one.
Thank you.
Thank you for talking about my nose.
But hey,
I didn't like the way you've talked
about my nose.
The fucking entire podcast was a thinly
veiled slight at my nose.
I mean he asked me to go online and
people are tweeting me half truths about
my nose.
You know what to do.
We're going to do.
They're going to subtly photoshop your
nose just slightly bigger and you know,
look at the picture like,
oh my god,
do I look like that?
And then you're going to go to the
bathroom and look at your notes.
Go,
what the fuck?
Well,
thank you for giving them this bang up
idea.
Well I know this guy who photoshops is
radio personality and he takes them and
he does like these subtle weird things
to his face.
He makes his teeth bigger and make some
bolder and he makes his hands smaller
and he makes his shoulders like more
narrow but just slightly.
When you look at him you go fuck is
going on with them and this and it
drives the radio guy.
I think probably crazy.
Does he know that the guys doing it
though or is he just thinks that he's
becoming disproportionate?
I think you know.
Well some of the pictures of the guys
more obvious and some of them is more
subtle but it's the.
But the fact that that's not what he
really looks like that.
But the fact that someone could take
what you look like and make it different
but just slightly but just will fuck
with you.
That's weird.
It's weird.
It's weird that you know,
your ears aren't too big,
but if somebody like stretches your ears
I just a little bit and makes them poke
out of your hair.
What the fuck is going on in my ears?
like that's the photoshop thing is a
weird thing.
It's weird that people could do that.
It's also weird that people use it to
manipulate their own image.
Face tuning.
Male comedian who,
who smooths hIs skin out and does it
like a glamour filter on a bad fake as
fuck.
It looks bizarre.
Like super bowl.
And then you see them In real life like,
hey,
where the fuck what did you have?
Chicken pox.
And last tIme I saw your photos.
She gonna fight with a fucking salt gun.
I think um,
those,
those things,
the ability to manipulate faces and the,
the photoshop thing and what they do to
models where they're thin out their ways
and wiping butts and you know,
if you've seen those,
those reality versus the photoshop
images overwhelming has changed.
and then I wish I could remember what I
was watching,
but it was something where they were
showing that they can do this to moving
images.
So movies,
you know,
like they showed the real version of the
actress in whatever movie versus what
you saw on screen.
And it was sort of the equivalent of the
photo shopped magazine cover.
Yeah,
I mean we're going to get to a point
very soon where actors are unnecessary
because if you look at some of the
incredible cgi that they're able to do
now,
where they're,
they're,
they're so close to absolutely
recreating a human being.
They're not going to need actors,
maybe voiceover actors to just even that
maybe they'll get to their point where
they're visual or audio software can
manipulate the human voice in the same
way that you could do wIth music
software where you could use garage band
songs without knowing any guitars.
So actors who are listening time to
start a podcast,
ah,
it's almost over bitches,
but it's not because you're never going
to be able to recreate like a Daniel
Day.
Lewis never like someone who can go that
deep into something.
It's almost,
it's almost like until he does it,
you don't know it can be done.
You know,
his,
his intense commitment to a character is
so.
It's so bizarre.
And it's also part of what you love
about watching that guy in the movies
that,
you know,
that's Daniel Day lewis,
during that first,
not first blood,
what is it called in,
there will be blood,
there will be blood character like,
you know,
that's him,
that's Daniel Day lewis.
But you also completely believe he's
this fucking guy that's half of the
thrill.
It's not just that someone does the
cirque de solei,
you know,
like look at the guy flipped,
that that's a person that had a practice
that they had to get so proficient that
they could do something that looks
impossible and then do it line by line
out of order.
That's
speakIng about recently.
I think my conception of acting is,
is almost like comes from a theater
world where it's like you put on a
costume and then you go be a different
person for two hours or whatever.
Like a theater movie,
amalgam.
Um,
but I shot this pilot recently and you
know,
everything was shot out of order as
things are when they're shot.
And it kind of gave me this insight into
like,
oh,
part so much of the skill is just your
ability to pick it up out of order and
act it out,
even though you know,
it's just,
it's so piecemeal.
Yeah.
What would Daniel Day lewis did?
the lincoln movie.
Apparently he was in character as
lincoln the entire time.
Talk to people as lincoln.
Everything he did as lincoln,
the aide is lincoln went to bed as
lincoln woke up as lincoln.
That's crazy.
It's a little much.
I agree.
Nutty dude to hang around with knowing
in that way because it was christian
bale.
Do that kind of stuff too.
You hear?
Sorry.
I mean you saw the machinist.
Do you ever see that movie?
You never saw that?
No.
I know I should though.
It's on my list.
Do you know what he did?
He lost a whole bunch of weight.
Right?
But he got to death's door.
I mean literally got to death's door.
He looked like an auschwitz victim.
I mean it's.
I don't know how a person allows
themselves to do that.
That's not a good image.
J jamie.
That's not a real image from the movie.
That's.
That's like a digital recreation.
That's him for real.
Yeah.
I saw.
I seen that picture.
Fuck man.
I mean he got to the point where his
body was shriveled away.
He had no body fat and he was dying.
He played a guy with severe insomnia
that started to have hallucinations and
was losing his fucking mind.
Really crazy shit.
But that someone takes it to that level,
but that's like one of the badges of
honor when it comes to those types of
actors,
like robert deniro.
He used to do that member in raging
bull,
like he got an incredible shape.
We got really lean,
looked like a boxer,
and then for the end of the movie got
really fat and he played like jake
lamata all swollen and filled with
spaghetti,
but who was it?
Who had that?
That famous quip is like,
why don't you just try acting?
Yeah.
I forget who it was.
I want to say.
let's just say it.
Whether it's true or not.
Yeah.
But meanwhile would have sir laurence
olivier play jake lamotta in raging
bull.
What did it have sucked?
What was good?
I suspect it would not have been as good
and probably whatnot have been.
Yeah,
I mean you like when he played that guy
in cape fear,
I mean to get into kind of shape that he
got in.
Remember when he's doing those chin ups,
like you believed that he was his rage
filled ex con that was coming to get
revenge.
Like he.
It seems like he approached life that
way.
It wasn't just,
he was acting like he had an adopted
this mindset and had it fully ingrained
in,
into who he was portraying on screen.
It's why those movies are so good.
Well,
maybe that is the difference between,
you know,
superstar powerhouse,
really compelling acting and just sort
of average acting is that they really
are living at versus they are acting it
out in a moment.
I mean you have to take it to the
utmost,
but that's also why it's so frustrating
to watch robert deniro in the intern
like jesus christ.
Did you see that?
No.
I watched clips of it on an airplane and
I was like,
what the fuck am I took my headphones
off.
Fuck,
am I watching stupid ass movie?
but it's just like,
this is a guy that was a part of like
some of the great cinematic
masterpieces.
he was in the godfather.
Ii was raging bull.
I mean,
he just like you.
the list goes on.
Taxi driver.
I mean,
he was in some fucking masterpieces.
Meet the fockers.
Wasn't he in that?
Probably.
Probably where it started.
probably realized like I don't even have
to act.
Remember these stupid words to say and
just get some fat money,
huh?
Yeah.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Well that's kind of like.
I feel like al pacino has just become a
caricature of apa.
Chino will.
He has a rant like clause in every
contract.
Whereas my rent,
he's got a rant and every fucking movie.
It all started from that devil movie we
played.
The devil remember,
had to go on that long ass ran as the
devil.
Come on.
DevIl would have some verbose bullshit
ass from rant,
right?
The devil doesn't need words.
Oh,
but he's good at the at word level.
Just eat a plate of babies in front of
you.
Doesn't have to say anything.
Fire.
Yeah,
exactly.
I gotta get out of here.
Alison rosen.
This is fun.
Let's do it again.
Which I would love to.
And people can get your podcasts
everywhere,
right?
Yes.
A itunes.com/alison rosen or a allison
resin.com or everywhere.
Everywhere.
Fuckers.
So wherever you are,
alison rosen is your best friend is your
new best friend,
but also your best friend.
Well,
okay,
there you go.
thank you.
Thank you for having me.
My pleasure.
See you next week.
You fucks.